MonkaW
Hallo?
Na Leute?
was geht
da kann das sein dass irgendwie die anzeige von viewer nicht funktioniert
los twitch
Ja, ja, hier, super, super Secret.
Ja, ja, hier, super.
Hat die Klappe, Max.
Zeigt das keine Viewer mehr an, oder?
Ist das normal?
Dass keine Viewer mehr angezeigt werden?
Oder ist das Twitch-Bug?
Ja, ja, aber du siehst hier, guck mal.
Von mir wird nichts vielleicht ist mein fenster zu groß jetzt
Keine ahnung
Der zoom ist es nicht das ist eben gerade das eingeblendet worden guck wenn ich wieder ran so gut dann geht sie okay
Keine ahnung egal macht dazu
Agiles development ja daily scrum leute jetzt
stand up
wo sind die emojis wieso welche emojis meinst du im titel oder was da hier
Rakete. Die Agile Rakete. Jan, dankeschön für den Sub.
Achso, du meinst die Emotes. Du kannst ein paar verwenden. Also die gehen nur mit Sub,
aber du kannst ein paar andere verwenden. Hier, es gibt ein paar. Gagball. Wir haben so viele
schwachsinn es gibt ein paar keks im aus die sind in ffz drin und schicko schicko ist auch am start
du musst zunächst deine handy nummer bestätigen damit diese nachricht gesendet werden kann genau
das was ich jetzt unbedingt hier live im stream machen muss ja mal ganz davon abgesehen ich habe
ihnen fake account mit irgendeiner fake e mail adresse also damit nichts verifizierte
hat sich
ausverifiziert.
Ups, falscher Knopf.
Mein Chat hat einen harten Delay.
Stimmt, der Chat
hat ein ziemliches Delay. Was ist da los?
Warte mal, lass mal was ausprobieren.
Test.
Ah, da jetzt geht's. Jetzt ist gut.
Ja, Pause Champ.
Jetzt ist gut.
Jetzt passt.
Manchmal muss man einfach nur reloaden.
Es ist eh erstaunlich.
Ne, ich bin nicht mehr bei der Bank.
Ich arbeite bei einer Versicherung.
Bei einer Bank habe ich gearbeitet vor
zwei Jahren.
Das habe ich aber auch.
habe ich aber glaube ich auch im Video
erzählt. Es ist eh erstaunlich,
wie viele Sachen Neustarts
beheben, gell Leute? Also
habe ich schon mal erzählt,
ich habe mal bei meinem Kühlschrank,
der hat mal Geräusche gemacht.
So ganz, war irgendwas mit der Pumpe oder so.
Ganz komische Geräusche.
Und ich habe nicht rausgefunden,
was das war.
Und irgendwann habe ich mir gedacht, wir machen jetzt
einen Reboot.
Stecker rausgezogen, Stecker wieder reingesteckt,
geräusche weg also reboot hilft bei deutlich mehr als man so denkt
hast du gar mehrere videos zu deiner wechsel war zu aktiv fast zuletzt bei
battlefield 3 by the way habe ich wieder installiert
ich glaube es nicht ich habe letztens battlefield 3 installiert und dann bin
ich in irgendeinen leeren server gejoined was ist denn das hier warum blinkt denn das da bin ich in irgendeinen leeren server gejoined um meine settings zu machen in game und da joint irgendein typ rein und sagt
Hey Max!
Hab ich auch gehabt, Alter!
Kommen die Leute immer her.
Ne, Battlefield 3 spielt sich nicht mal gut, weil die Server immer crashen.
Die Rush-Server, kannst keinen Rush mehr spielen.
Ja, ich bin wieder am Start.
Ich kann euch mal kurz, falls es irgendwelche Fragen gibt, haut rein.
Ist das nicht normalerweise Essenszeit jetzt?
Ne, ich habe schon gegessen.
Ich habe Hähnchen.
Hähnchen.
Hähnchen mit Nudel.
Habe ich gegessen.
Wobei, sind das wirklich Nudel?
Ne, kein Lachs.
Lachs habe ich tatsächlich schon ein bisschen her.
Was?
Fahrrad?
Ne, ne, ne.
sind das wirklich nudeln sind schupf nudeln sind das wirklich nudeln geht
das das sind eigentlich keine richtigen nudeln das sind eher so klöschen oder
sowas wenn man so will oder das habe ich heute gegessen mit hähnchen dabei hähnchen
Also, weiß nicht, ob das als Nudel durchgeht.
Wie fandest du die Battlefield 6 Beta?
Ich konnte die Battlefield 6 Beta nicht spielen.
Weil, ich glaube, ich habe mich da auch...
Ich schreibe immer noch Twitter und finde da trotzdem.
Ich glaube, ich habe mich da auch schön auf...
Alter, X ist so scheiße geworden.
Du findest nichts mehr.
Egal, ich sage es euch.
Ich konnte die Battlefield 6 Beta nicht spielen, weil ich keinen Secure Boot anhabe.
By the way, wir machen mal kurz Package.
Ich habe so lange diese VM nicht mehr angehabt.
Ich mache mal einen Snapshot, bevor ich Package-Updates mache.
Ich hab noch das Delay vom Kreiselgrind
Ne
Ich hab hier den Vorschau
Mein Delay ist ungefähr
Ist ungefähr
Eine Sekunde
Oder was hab ich für ein Delay
Guck mal, ich schalte jetzt um
Und jetzt seh ich, dass ich umgeschaltet hab
Also sind 2-3 Sekunden
wartet mal kurz
so
also 2 Sekunden
Delay habe ich nicht wirklich viel
reloade mal bei dir
ja was wollte ich jetzt eigentlich sagen
ja genau also Battlefield 6 Beta
ich konnte nicht spielen
deswegen Secure Boot
ich habe ja mein System mit
VeraCrypt voll verschlüsselt
und ich habe nachdem ich Battlefield 6 installiert habe
und versucht habe zu starten
also schon den Tag vorher
oder wann das war, konnte man ja schon installieren
und irgendwie updaten, da wollte ich versuchen zu starten
hat er gesagt, hier starte
weiß nicht, irgendwie so Anti-Cheat-Gedöns
und dann kam eine Meldung, das geht nicht
weil ich keinen Secure-Boot habe
so, da bin ich
jetzt auch am überlegen
wie ich das wie was ich mache ja entweder entschlüssel ich das alles wobei ich habe
ja die ich habe die festplatte nicht verschlüsselt aus irgendwelchen zwielichtigen gründen oder so
sondern einfach aus dem grund dass ich eine platte also dass ich ein platten wegschmeißen
kann so ohne mir gedanken machen zu müssen ja oder keine ahnung vielleicht spricht irgendwann
mal jemand ein und klaut meinen Rechner oder
whatever. Ich weiß meiner nie, was
was mal ist, ja. Aber eher hauptsächlich,
dass ich die Platten wegschmeißen kann. Stellt euch
vor, ihr habt ja, ihr habt alles mögliche
von WiFi-Credentials bis irgendwelche
Äh, Arztrechnungen.
Keine Ahnung, habt ihr alles mögliche
Zeug auf dem Rechner.
Ja, BitLocker trau ich nicht. BitLocker trau ich
schon seit Anfang an nicht.
Seitdem es mal eine News gab,
dass man
vergessene Pa... Ich weiß gar nicht, inwieweit
das überhaupt noch stimmt, ja.
dass man vergessene Passwörter
von BitLocker
recoveren kann. Und ab dem
Zeitpunkt wusste ich, dass
BitLocker suckt.
Was ist eigentlich
mit die Festplatte Secure zu Erasen?
Das geht auch. Du kannst die Festplatte auch einmal
mit Nullen überschreiben. Aber warum
ich das mache, ist ja, stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt da
auf der Festplatte Sachen drauf,
wo ihr vielleicht nicht
wollt, dass das irgendjemand sieht. Ja, manch einer hat
irgendwelche
Ports drauf, die er nicht will, dass man
sieht andere haben passwörter wifi credentials arbeitsverträge oder einfach
ja also leute haben irgendwas drauf so stellt euch mal vor die festplatte geht
euch kaputt und ihr könnt ihr nicht mehr löschen da ist ja im prinzip noch alles
drauf wiederherstellbar kann man sagen ja ist mir egal aber ich finde passwörter
und credentials im klartext quasi in die mülltonne schmeißen irgendwie doof es
wird zu 99 prozent nichts passieren aber wenn man wirklich seine passwörter im klartext in die
mülltonne schmeißen wenn die festplatte nicht mehr richtig funktioniert dann kannst du dir nicht mehr
secure löschen und damit ich überhaupt keine gedanken machen muss und alles in die mülltonne
hauen kann wie ich will habe ich einfach alles komplett voll verschlüsselt seit jahren schon
sind über zehn jahren früher mit true crypt jetzt mit vera crypt übrigens leute kennt ihr das beste
shell kommando überhaupt vmchamp kek w das ist das einzige was noch funktioniert alles andere
ist kaputt der vmchamp outdated ist so aber ich wollte mal gerade package updates machen
wenn wir schon dabei sind.
Ja, vielleicht erzähle ich euch auch eine,
wo ich gesteckt habe.
Beziehungsweise, wow.
Alter.
Beziehungsweise, warum ich
so wenig streame.
Oder YouTube und sonst was.
Fiat.
Fiat Champ wurde geforkt.
Fiat Champ wurde geforkt und mittlerweile hat
sogar einer ein richtiges Home Assistant Plugin
ins, ähm,
Plugin daraus gebaut.
also eigentlich braucht man den Fiat Champ gar nicht mehr wobei ich den Fiat Champ immer noch am besten finde
Ich bin keine, ne ne ne, keine Kinder
Viel banaler
Ja ich würde sagen ich update mal
Update mal, bei der Gelegenheit können wir auch, wir machen einfach komplettes Update von allem
Toolbox
jet brains toolbox dies brauchen ach die stadt auf dem desktop ist die offen da
wird auch alles geupdatet zack check for updates beim alles
updaten was dem knast
Okay
Chat
Wollt ihr wissen, warum ich gerade nicht so viel streamen kann?
Ist aber nicht so erfreulich
Kann ich euch gleich schon dazu sagen
Wollt ihr wissen, warum ich gerade kein YouTube-Zeug mache
Und nicht so viel streame?
Ich kann euch das jetzt nicht so sehr
Wann die Malware-Analyse
Das weiß ich nicht, ob ich das noch mache
Also
Ich kann euch das nicht alles so im Detail erzählen
Burnout, naja, das geht fast schon in die richtige Richtung
Ja, ja, Krankheit trifft es ganz gut
Ich
Ich sag mal so
Ich krieg mittlerweile Pillen
Gegen Depressionen und Angststörungen
Und woher das Ganze kommt
ich habe keine richtige Ahnung.
Das hat letztes Jahr
irgendwann
im Oktober,
November angefangen.
Und
ja,
so richtig
hundertprozentig erklären kann man sich's nicht.
So richtig
random.
Und
also keine ahnung warum das woher weiß nicht so genau aber ich krieg hast du schon probiert das
hier ein auszuschalten und wieder einzuschalten das wäre nice wenn man hier ein rebooten könnte
ja da würde ich das machen long covid quatsch und das das war auch erst gar nicht so klar ja
was der sache ist ich habe das selbst ja nicht richtig gecheckt und ich habe mir dann auch einen
neuen hausarzt gesucht weil ich hatte keinen bock mehr auf meinen alten mit dem habe ich mich nie
verstanden und ich bin halt auch eine ganze weile nicht zum arzt gegangen ich habe gedacht dass sie
wie normal irgendwas ich wusste dass was nicht stimmt aber nicht aber nicht was und irgendwann
habe ich mir gedacht du solltest jetzt vielleicht doch mal zum arzt gehen und da habe ich mir neuen
hausarzt gesucht hier in frankfurt wo man das geliebten erst jetzt wird er jetzt jetzt jetzt
jetzt wir geliebten das alles alter der justin krommlinger okay soll ich mal wald und darauf
jetzt hier läuft gleich weiter ich an install den ganzen krempel marl
Prometheus
So
No
Fucking No Chairs
Was ist da los
Ah
Monka
Okay, vielleicht geht's jetzt
Leute, ihr müsst hier nicht analysieren
Großartig, das
überlasse ich den Experts
Naja, zumindest keine Ahnung
wo das Ganze genau herkommt
und ich hab's am Anfang ja auch nicht
wirklich gecheckt
Und irgendwann hab ich mir gedacht
ja genau, hab ich erzählt, musst dir jetzt mal
einen ordentlichen Hausarzt suchen.
Dann deleten wir es halt nicht. Geht's denn dann, wenn ich es nicht delete?
Hab ich mir einen neuen Hausarzt gesucht.
Und der hat auch schon gesagt,
ah, da muss man mal gucken.
Und, ähm...
Ja, das hat
sich dann alles hingezogen.
Weil es
irgendwie keiner so...
Alter, was ist das für ein Scheiß?
Weil es irgendwie keiner so genau wusste.
Und jetzt
seit
ähm
ja, seit Ende
Juli
habe ich jetzt Pillen dagegen.
Und ich habe mir mittlerweile auch einen Therapeut
gesucht und rede mit
dem ab und zu.
Das ist mega krass, wenn man das überlegt.
Vor zwei Jahren
ging es mir so gut wie noch nie.
Ich war mega fit.
Bin ich übrigens immer noch.
Bin ja ganz so fit, aber immer noch relativ fit.
Ich war mega fit und super gut drauf und alles.
Und irgendwann ging es dann so ab
Oktober, November letztes Jahr
so bergab.
Naja, zumindest
mache ich das jetzt.
Und
ja, also was letztendlich geholfen hat,
ist
also wie gesagt, ich kriege es seit Ende
Juli
habe ich jetzt Pillen
und die helfen
auch, das ging aber erst
als ich gesagt habe, ey, das kann ich
mir nicht mehr so lange
kann ich mir nicht mehr angucken, dann bin ich nach
Frankfurt in die
Psychiatrie, in die Ambulanz gefahren
ich habe gesagt, ey, ich habe keinen Bock mehr
auf den Scheiß, du fährst jetzt zu
irgendjemand, der Ahnung hat
ich habe erst gedacht
so, Alter, kannst doch da nicht einfach hinfahren.
Ich habe mir
irgendwann so gedacht, Alter, es reicht
jetzt mal.
Dann bin ich ernsthaft nach Frankfurt in die Psychiatrie
gefahren, in die Ambulanz, kann man sich
anmelden.
Und die waren echt nice,
muss man sagen.
Und die haben gesagt,
es gibt total viele, die sowas haben.
Also ich glaube, 20% der
Leute kriegen das im Laufe des Lebens mal
sowas in die Richtung.
Und
die haben mir da ein paar Pillen aufgeschrieben.
Da darfst du natürlich
nicht den Nebenwirkungszettel dir durchlesen.
Weil
da ist alles dabei, bis
plötzlicher Tod, ja.
Und
wenn du das durchliest,
da denkst du, kratzt gleich ab, wenn du das nimmst.
Plötzlicher,
ja, das ist immer krass, ne.
egal zumindest nehme ich das jetzt seit ein paar wochen und seitdem geht es
wirklich langsam aber sicher besser ist nicht alles komplett weg aber es ist
insgesamt entspannter wieder her
ich nehme sehr traurigen falls das jemand interessiert das sind pillen
gegen Depressionen und Angstzustände.
Wobei Depressionen habe ich keine.
Haben die zumindest gesagt.
Tja.
So sieht's aus, hä?
Ja.
Und...
Achso, ja, angefangen...
Stimmt, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte.
angefangen hat das ganze so ganz unscheinbar ich konnte schlecht schlafen
da denkst du dir erst mal nichts bei herr
text irgendwann denkst du dir halt einfach nicht
keine ahnung was soll das schon sein also hat das angefangen dass ich nicht
richtig schlafen konnte mehr und dass ich mir da angefangen habe übelst
Gedanken zu machen, was los ist.
Und man steigert
sich ja dann halt auch mit der Zeit ein bisschen rein, ja,
in die ganze Geschichte.
Ja, also es hat bei mir jetzt fast,
wenn man mal
denkt, das ist Oktober, November,
jetzt haben wir August. Musst ihr euch mal
vorstellen, es hat fast ein Jahr
gedauert.
Zum Thema Krankenversicherung will ich nichts sagen,
das ist mir zu viel Beschäftigung mit
so, bin ich, ja.
Zu viel Beschäftigung mit Gesundheitssachen, da habe ich gerade keinen Bock drauf.
Muss ich mal überlegen, das hat fast ein Jahr gedauert, bis man da jetzt drauf gekommen ist.
Ja, was eigentlich Sache ist.
In der Zwischenzeit habe ich schon echt ein paar Mal da gesessen und habe mir gedacht, Alter, was ist denn los? Kann doch alles nicht mehr sein.
es hat fast ein Jahr gedauert
bis ich
bis da mal einer
drauf gekommen ist
hier, lasst mal das mit den Pillen probieren
da musste ich echt wirklich
erst zu den Profis
nach Frankfurt fahren
dass das
funktioniert hat
und deswegen hatte ich auch ein bisschen wenig Antrieb
in letzter Zeit und immer noch
ja und wie gesagt so ganz weg
ist das nicht das scheint auch normal zu sein weil solche erkrankungen dass das
immer so ein bisschen in wellen verläuft mal besser mal schlechter dadurch dass
ich jetzt dass ich jetzt diese pillen nehme ist es halt nie so richtig ganz
schlecht mehr und ja es ist auf jeden fall seitdem besser
ja also
jetzt geht es mir ganz gut gerade wieder
Aber ich laufe noch und mache es da auch gerade langsamer.
Da mache ich auch gerade ein bisschen langsamer.
Um was geht's?
Warum ich die letzte Zeit nicht so oft da war.
So.
Jetzt müssen wir aber mal kurz gucken, warum ich mein System nicht updaten kann.
Das wäre nämlich ganz praktisch, weil dann könnten wir heute noch was Sinnvolles machen.
Aber eins kann ich euch sagen, Leute.
Nochmal noch jetzt mal das unerfreuliche Thema abzuhaken.
Schlafstörungen sind echt scheiße.
so hat das nämlich bei mir angefangen
und
irgendwann
macht ihr euch dann so viel Gedanken
dass ihr nicht mehr schlafen könnt
nicht weil ihr Schlafstörungen habt
sondern Schlafstörungen habt weil ihr euch so viel Gedanken macht
und dann sitzt ihr dann da
und habt übelste Panik weil ihr nicht wisst was los ist
und denkt
ich würde mich nicht wundern was ihr vielleicht Schlimmes habt
weil es muss ja einen Grund haben
am Anfang eigentlich eher nur
wachgelegen, aber ich hab dann angefangen
mir übelst Gedanken zu machen
was denn los ist
und später war es dann so
dass ich eigentlich eher wachgelegen hab
weil ich mir so viele Gedanken gemacht hab
also wisst ihr, das hat sich gewandelt von
erstmal konnte ich einfach nur nicht gut schlafen
zu ich mach mir Gedanken darüber
warum ich nicht gut schlafen kann und kann deswegen nicht pennen
Ja, also das ist wirklich
Das ist richtig kacke
Also ich hab teilweise ja gar nicht gepennt die Nacht
Und wenn ihr mal ne Nacht wirklich
Auf nachts einfach nur rumgesessen habt
Und übelst Panik hattet
Dass ihr irgendwie was Schlimmes habt
Weil es muss ja irgendwo ran liegen, ja
Letztendlich versucht man sich ja im Kopf
Irgendwie so zusammenzureimen, was könnte es denn sein
Und kommt bloß nicht, Leute ich sag euch eins, ja
Googelt nicht
fangt nicht an ich habe den fehler gemacht ich habe angefangen zu googeln
leute ihr habt alles von gehirntumor bis whatever wenn ihr googelt googelt ist
es wirklich eine ganz schlechte idee
ja nein nein nein chat gpt ist auch nicht besser chat gpt ist viel zu
schwammig und sagt euch ja auch irgendwie die unwahrscheinlichsten
Wahrscheinlichkeiten, ja.
Also Google ist ganz schlimm,
wenn ihr sowas, also wenn ihr eh schon ein bisschen
Bedenken habt, was so Gesundheitssachen und so
angeht, googelt auf gar keinen Fall.
Also das ist wirklich das
Allerschlechteste, was ihr machen könnt, ja.
Ja.
Ja, zumindest das ist
wirklich kacke. Ich kann nicht
sagen, ab wann Schlafstörungen sind, ab dann, wo du
die Scheiße fühlst damit, ja, würde ich sagen.
Ja, das ist so. Zumindest, nachdem, was ich jetzt noch sagen wollte, nachdem das bei mir so angefangen hat, kann man nicht richtig schlafen, ist ja sehr unspezifisch.
Überlegt mal, ob ihr nicht vielleicht irgendeinen unbewussten Stressfaktor habt oder irgendwas, wo ihr Angst vor habt oder euch Gedanken macht oder sonst was.
Ob es nicht vielleicht auch an irgendwas am Kopf liegen kann.
und da denkt man eigentlich viel zu
viel zu selten dran oder viel zu
viel zu spät dran
weil
umso später man das merkt
umso schwieriger ist es natürlich auch
beziehungsweise, naja, umso schwieriger nicht
umso länger dauert es natürlich auch
bis man da wieder raus ist
weil man hängt dann halt irgendwie im Kopf da so drauf
wie gesagt, bei mir hat das jetzt fast ein Jahr gedauert
bis dann einer auf die Idee gekommen ist
mal ordentliche Pillen dagegen zu nehmen
und die bringen auch wirklich was.
Also,
ich muss so sagen,
man kann dagegen was machen.
Also ich nehme jetzt, ich kann das sagen,
ich nehme, wobei das eine
weiß ich gar nicht, was es ist, ich nehme
Sertralin, das ist
gegen Depressionen und Angstzustände
und ich nehme
noch irgendwas anderes
abends zum Beruhigen, zum besser schlafen.
da weiß ich jetzt nicht genau wie das heißt
und wichtig ist
als ihr irgendwie einfach nur zu eurem Hausarzt
geht und der dann nicht so viel Ahnung von hat
lasst euch nichts aufschreiben was
abhängig macht
das ist nur, das ist wirklich
viele Hausärzte machen das, die haben keinen Bock
sich damit groß zu beschäftigen
geben euch dann irgendwelche Pillen die abhängig machen
sowas kann man mal in
extremen Situationen machen
wenn gar nichts
geht
ja, aber
da muss man aufpassen
also guckt, dass ihr keine Pillen nehmt, die abhängig
machen
auch wenn es euch der Arzt verschrieben hat
und der irgendwie nur, geht lieber gleich
zu den Leuten, die Ahnung haben mit sowas
das war mir auch wichtig
und deswegen bin ich eigentlich ganz froh mit dem, was
die mir da jetzt gegeben haben
einmal halt die Sache
einmal die Pillen, die gegen die eigentliche Sache helfen
und dann abends noch was
was mich abhängig macht zum einschlafen ja so sieht es aus ja das stimmt wohl
dankeschön für den sub machst du noch mal kurz zusammenfassen was okay ich
sag's noch mal in zwei sätzen für alle jetzt dazwischen dabei gekommen sind ich
war nicht da bzw youtube muss gerade mal gucken ob nicht irgendein ob ich nicht
das ab vergessen habe
für den zapf ich war nicht da ich habe psychische probleme unbemerkt gehabt
seit letztem jahr oktober november so richtig so richtig was dagegen macht
gemacht wird jetzt erst seit ende juli aber da mal richtig gesagt hat okay
erstmal richtig drauf gekommen ist
und
das und
wirklich drauf
gekommen ist man eigentlich so richtig erst
als ich in die ambulante
Psychiatrie in Frankfurt gefahren bin und gesagt
hab, Jungs, ey, mit mir stimmt was nicht.
Und die waren da wirklich, also da muss
man echt sagen, man kennt das ja
so aus Fernsehsendungen und sowas,
so Psychiatrie, ganz schlimm.
Die waren da wirklich sehr nett
und hatten Ahnung.
Ja, deswegen, also meine Hausärztin
ist wirklich, die ist wirklich sehr nice.
Die hat das ja auch gesagt. Die hat ja auch zu mir
gesagt, ich soll da hinfahren.
Ja, die meisten Hausärzte
sind planlos, was solche Sachen angeht.
Die hat ja auch zu mir gesagt, ich soll da hinfahren.
Und ich hab zu ihr gesagt, ich will da
nicht hin.
Das ist doch ganz schlimm und sowas.
ja wahrscheinlich weil man das so aus film und fernsehen und so kennt wollte ich nicht hinfahren
die hat gesagt doch fahren sie dahin das ist überhaupt nicht schlimm sie kennt da auch ein
paar leute es ist überhaupt nicht schlimm muss man sich überhaupt keine gedanken machen und dann habe
ich mal wieder danach so richtig beschissen gepennt weil ich mir so viele gedanken gemacht
habe also habe ich gesagt leute ich fahre da jetzt hin da bin ich nach frankfurt in die ambulanz
gefahren musste musste irgendwie mit spinnen oder so habe ich da gesessen gewartet nachdem
ich angemeldet habe und dann ging das und die haben sich wirklich zeit genommen ich war da
bestimmt 35 40 minuten dort beinahe bei einer ärztin in der ambulanz und die hat das alles
ich noch mal erklären lassen und hat dann gesagt hat er auch gesagt also ich habe ja auch ich habe
dann zu ihr gesagt ja ich habe so bedenken dass das gar nicht mehr weg geht weil es jetzt so
lange ist die hat auch gesagt soll mir keine gedanken machen es haben total viele und sind
über zehn jahren wo sie hier ist noch nicht eingesehen wurde es nicht wieder weg gegangen
ist und hat mir da halt die pillen aufgeschrieben dafür und diese 22 pillen und da muss man echt
sagen also seitdem ist das auch wirklich konzert zugucken von woche zu woche besser geworden also
ganz und in so ganz instant weg ist das netz und wird jetzt auch wahrscheinlich ein bisschen dauern
bis das alles wieder komplett weg ist.
Aber es ist nicht mehr so schlimm.
Ja, und das hat jetzt, wenn man sich überlegt,
bestimmt, sag mal, 10 Monate gedauert
oder so, bis man da drauf gekommen ist,
richtig.
Ja, moin Patrick, 74 Monate.
Massive Subscriptions hier.
Huge.
Ich finde, ich finde meine...
Oh, hab ich denn meinen Nice? Hier.
Den hab ich gesucht.
besser spät als nie
so sieht's aus
ich habe sogar Leute angeschrieben in YouTube kommen es auf Twitter und so
so er war es ist alles okay
okay ich hab jetzt
Ich habe jetzt hier nicht so viel Entwupplos gesehen.
Also, wenn ihr noch irgendwelche Fragen habt,
jetzt nicht unbedingt zu so Krankheitsgeschichten,
reicht jetzt auch, ja.
Allgemein, so Technikkrams oder was immer ihr wissen wollt,
schreibt es in den Chat und schreibt am besten Entwupplos davor,
damit ich das sehe.
So, ich wollte ja eigentlich Package updaten.
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen? Warum geht denn der Scheiß nicht?
Simt Jason.
Will nicht. Löschen.
Warum?
warum nicht
No js okay dann ist dann sollen wir auch no js
Ok no js geht nicht weil sam wäre und npm und das und das kann er nicht einfach
What the fuck
monka hess okay darf ich jetzt updaten vielleicht freige leute freige war ja
Danke schön für den Sub.
Das passiert bei Arch eigentlich nicht, wenn du öfters ab...
Was hat er denn jetzt für Schmerzen?
Hast du dir mal CachyOS angeschaut?
Nee.
Ich hab letztens ein Video über CachyOS.
Ähm.
Wie ging das nochmal zu gucken?
Pac-Man minus...
UO?
Leute,
Fivehead. Hätte ich das gewusst aus dem Kopf.
Da kann man nämlich gucken,
zu welchem Package die Datei gehört.
Linux-Firmware. Moment.
Kann man Linux-Firmware einfach
aninstallen? Geht das?
oder ist dann meine
VM im Arsch?
Möpp,
danke schön für den Sub.
Ich habe ja einen Stepshot gemacht vorher.
Also auf der Arbeit würde ich
wahrscheinlich auch kein Archilux als
System, von dem ich Boote einsetzen.
Da sind ja die Chancen, dass ab und zu mal was kaputt geht,
schon höher als
jetzt bei irgendeinem Stable, Ubuntu oder Debian.
Okay.
Kann ich jetzt updaten?
Hey.
Progu.
Meinungslebe an 13.
Ehrlich gesagt habe ich mir das nicht näher angeguckt.
Ich...
Also...
Vor allem aus dem Grund, weil Debian-Releases eigentlich immer sehr unspektakulär sind.
Und ich gehe davon aus, das ist jetzt auch so, oder?
Ja, ich installiere das Firmware auch gleich wieder, sobald ich hier die Updates durch habe.
Debian 13 ist bestimmt sehr unspektakuläres, typisches Debian-Release.
Es ist eine neue Debian-Version, die schon veraltet ist bei Release, aber noch nicht so krass.
Und halt wieder Stable AF.
also wahrscheinlich ein super system für seine server oder container base images oder sonst was
was ist damit gibt es da was neues
das haben wir auch schon im stream gemacht kann sich noch daran erinnern da warst du
glaube ich auch im stream du bist ja fast jeden und jedem stream da haben wir auch
schon im stream gemacht
das war vor einer zeit wirklich ewig dabei oder gut das haben wir das haben
wir tatsächlich schon im stream gemacht guck wo blort garmin
Ja.
AI-Generated Images.
Guck da.
Haben wir gemacht.
Äh, für den Fahrradcomputer.
Was sagst du denn zum neuen Battlefield?
Ich kann dazu nicht viel sagen.
Ich hab Videos geguckt und Streams geguckt.
Ich hatte den Eindruck, dass das mal wieder ein Battlefield ist, was zumindest auf den ersten Blick nach Battlefield aussieht.
Was mir überhaupt nicht gefallen hat, war die Maps, die ich gesehen habe, beziehungsweise gerade die eine Map mit den Hochhäusern.
Die war so komplett random, wo ich mir gedacht habe, wer hat denn diese Map wieder gebaut?
So vertikal, ohne Frontlinien, wo man weiß, wo Gegner herkommen können.
Wo ich sage, richtig, richtig kacke.
Rest kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Rest kann ich nichts zu sagen,
dazu muss ich das selbst spielen.
So, ich glaube, die Updates haben funktioniert.
Dann machen wir nochmal hier
Git Shit Package Upgrades.
So.
Jetbrains Sachen haben wir schon geupdatet.
Das haben wir.
Ähm.
Der Kram hier, der kann sich jetzt
updaten.
Warum skippt das
PGB
PGP Signatures
Soll das das
Ist das eine gute Idee
Soll das das skippen
Bin mir da nicht ganz sicher
Ob das so eine gute Idee ist
Beta war ein bisschen
Codlike
Naja
War nicht vom Gameplay
Damals sogar Battlefield 3 auch ein bisschen
kotlack bin ich finde ich an sich gar nicht so schlecht
das ist ja nicht automatisch schlimm
das wurde battlefield 3 auch damals nachgesagt
ja ich bin immer noch der meinung dass wiederbelebende system in berg ach so
Oh, und dass es jetzt eine Support-Klasse mit Defi gibt, das finde ich komisch.
So die Kombination aus LMG und Defi.
Man muss aber dazu sagen, das gab es ja schon mal in Bad Company war das auch so.
Genau, in Bad Company war das so.
Und in Bad Company 1 war das noch extremer.
Da gab es, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, gab es eine Support-Klasse.
Die hatte auch eine LMG.
Aber die hatte alles mögliche an Support.
Die hatte Mörser, Medipack.
ich glaube sogar reparieren ich glaube sogar reparieren für panzer hatte die hat den bett
company 1 die die support klasse und nicht und nicht der engineer gab es da glaube ich gar nicht
da gab es da gab es nur ein specialist und irgendwas mit shotguns und so wird
company 1 hat ein komisches klassensystem gehabt fehlende waffen lockt finde ich auch doof weil ich
der meinung bin dass gerade mal so liegt die bestimmten waffen kategorien eben zu dem zu
dem kit einfach dazu gehören ja dass du sagst hey engineer hat hauptsächlich smg soll dann
hauptsächlich Assault Rifles,
Recon hat eine Mischung
aus
Bolt Action und
Single Fire Dingern
und sowas. Ich finde es nicht
verkehrt,
wenn es ein paar übergreifende
Klassen, äh,
ein paar übergreifende Waffen gibt für alle Klassen, aber
so im Großen und Ganzen
finde ich, sollte ein Großteil der Waffen
gelockt auf das Kit sein.
Äh,
ja, habe ich ja gerade gesagt, also
ich kann nicht, ich hab gesagt, dass ich nicht viel
zu sagen kann, weil ich es nicht selbst spielen konnte.
Also,
ich fand, dass es zum ersten Mal wieder nach einem
ordentlichen Battlefield ausgeschaut hat.
Mit aber halt ein paar Sachen,
die mir nicht gefallen. Beispielsweise diese Hochhaus-Map
sah ganz grausam aus.
Deine Empfehlung
für ein Home-Energy-Management-System
möchte ich. EVCC
für Elektroautos.
Habe ich keine Empfehlung
für. Ich habe selbst keine
solar panels auf dem dach werde ich auch nicht machen weil teuer als fuck und du
findest keine leute ist gerade machen
was ist warum dauert das eigentlich gerade so lange mit dem update was was
macht er da warum braucht er fünf stunden für dieses eine package was
macht er denn extrakt irgendwas ach das ist das icon das icon theme ja das
dauert immer ewig im updaten weil das weil es drei millionen kleine dateien
oder so hat soll ich euch mal sagen was mein mein absolut lieblings battlefield
wäre oder oder was ich mir wünschen würde so man nur ganz grob gesehen will
keine da keine powerpoint präsentation darüber halten wenn die mal sagen würden ich habe nichts
ich habe nichts gegen service game und so was ja wenn ihr einfach mal sagen würden okay wir
veröffentlichen das spiel nicht zum frühestmöglichen zeitpunkt sondern wenn die sagen würden okay wir
haben jetzt ein spiel das ist soweit soweit so gut und das dann einfach noch
mal zwei jahre länger entwickeln indem sie es erstens intern ausgiebig selber
spielen und testen und und richtig ordentlich content reinpacken zu release
also nicht jetzt irgendwie 67 maps und ein bisschen sondern wirklich mal
komplett vollgeschissen also im positiven in positiven sinne mit inhalt
und Tiefe.
Ich entdecke heute noch auf Battlefield
3 Maps Stellen,
wo ich mir denke, ey,
da hat sich ja einer was bei gedacht, dass
da eine Kiste steht, dass man nicht sieht, wenn
einer durch die Nebenstraße durchhüpft und sowas.
Das denke ich mir heute noch.
Wann ist das rausgekommen?
2012 oder so?
13? Keine Ahnung.
Das ist uralt. Denke ich mir heute noch.
Und sowas hätte ich halt auch gerne wieder.
Man darf nicht vergessen,
Battlefield 3
hat glaube ich 29 Maps
mit den ganzen
DLCs. Warum bringen die
nicht mal Battlefield raus, nicht zum frühestmöglichen
Zeitpunkt, sondern wenn das Game
fertig ist, wenn die sagen, ey, das lässt sich gut spielen
und sonst was, einfach nochmal ein Jahr
warten und wirklich
Inhalt reinhauen, sodass die
Leute quasi halb erschlagen werden
bei Release, sodass du richtig mal wieder
ein Game hast, wo du nicht denkst,
schon nach irgendwie 2-3 Wochen spielen,
boah, ey, jetzt kommt wieder die scheiß Map,
habe ich wieder keinen bock drauf jetzt ist das hier zu 580 war und sowas und
dann können die ja auch ein service game draus machen dass das finde ich mal nice
also vom gameplay her ist mein lieblings battlefield e battlefield 3
also wenn es danach geht könnten die im prinzip einfach battlefield 3 nehmen und
sagen leute wir supporten das jetzt einfach wieder
da werde ich sofort dabei
also da kann ich dir nichts zu empfehlen aber ich bin mir selbst nicht am start
Hast du eigentlich Tipps für den Einstieg als Junior-Cloud-Admin?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ähm, die Ba... die Ba... wie, wie, wie, wie hat man das nochmal gesagt?
Das ist immer noch nicht fertig.
Die Basics.
Oder wie musste man das nochmal aussprechen?
Ähm, ja, die Basics.
Beherrschen.
Die Basics.
Basics.
Ja.
die Basics beherrschen.
Das ist, glaube ich, so ziemlich das Beste,
was du machen kannst als Einstieg. Also,
guck dir Containerisierung an,
guck dir Terraform an, guck dir mal
ein bisschen die unterschiedlichen Cloud-Anbieter
an.
Nee, nee, nee, Entra-ID nicht unbedingt.
Äh, bei Cloud, also
Cloud-Admin kommt drauf an, in welche
Richtung, ja? Aber ich,
ich, ich seh's jetzt mal eher so
aus dem DevOps-Bereich, wo's eher um
Infrastruktur geht, weniger als irgendwie um
Cloud Active Directory oder sowas.
Die Basics. Also musst du dir angucken, wie Terraform
funktioniert. Du musst ein bisschen Ahnung haben, was die ganzen
Cloud... Ich meine, letztendlich,
wenn du dir die drei großen
Cloud-Anbieter anguckst, wobei manche jetzt behaupten würden,
Google wäre eigentlich gar keiner der großen drei.
Ist er, glaube ich, auch nicht.
Ich glaube, rein von User-Zahlen ist es
AWS,
gefolgt von Azure,
gefolgt von Ali,
Cloud?
Fragezeichen?
Da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher.
Und irgendwann, wann kommt Google oder so?
aber so in unseren in unserem bereich ist es eigentlich google amazon und microsoft
die digital ocean glaube ich nicht libel cloud ja was macht die magenta cloud so sich angucken
was es bei den unterschiedlichen cloud anbietern gibt es ist da eh sehr viel überschneidung
dazwischen aber hauptsächlich die basics vor angefangen von terraform bis image
bauen containerisierung solche geschichten
müssen wir mal gedanken darüber machen was noch alles aber so was der richtung
Ja, vielleicht auch mal die ein oder andere Pipeline gebaut mit GitHub Actions.
Oder irgendeinem anderen Tool deiner Wahl.
Aber ich finde GitHub Actions da ganz nice.
GitLab CI oder irgendwas nehmen.
Manch einer macht ja auch noch was mit Jenkins.
Ich mag Jenkins.
Also bisschen Docker, bisschen Terraform ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
ich persönlich mag jenkins weil jenkins einfach so einen so einen so eine hülle
im endeffekt ist wurde wurde im endeffekt rein schmeißen kannst was du willst
letztendlich in vielen fällen ist jenkins ja quasi
einen gui um best zu starten wenn du so ist
die medien gestalt der entwicklung von das kann ich verstehen gerade was so bild erst
bilderstellung und sowas angeht da sehe ich sehr viel von kai erledigen in zukunft erledigt werden
also bei mir mache ich mir da wenig gedanken darüber wenn ich überlege was sie sich in
richtung also gerade auch bei programmierer softwareentwicklung was
ich ja die ki für zeug zusammen halluziniert
der ki wird uns nicht ersetzen
das habe ich nie verwendet beim alten arbeitgeber habe ich eine schulung
gemacht da haben sie das gezeigt und das war so übertrieben hakelig dass ich
gedacht habe gut dass wir nicht verwenden müssen
der scientist geiler job geile job bezeichnung
so hat er sich über updates funktioniert updates
yes wir haben noch nicht angefangen irgendwas zu machen heute egal übrigens
während ich rieb ich muss euch mal was zeigen ich würde mir gern neues fahrrad
kaufen aber ich kaufe mir kein neues fahrrad aber ich wollte ich was zeigen weil ich das mega nice
find so sind die habe ich jetzt alles geupdatet ich habe die chat brain sachen geupdatet ich habe
eine system packages geupdatet ich habe die hour packages geupdatet naja noch neueste neueste dort
netz sollte vielleicht noch installieren da gibt es ja mittlerweile schon die 10er beta läuft der
Fiat noch, ja.
Klar.
Morgen wird er gefahren.
Bist du noch auf meinem Sportcrime?
Ich habe ein bisschen
wenig Antrieb die
letzter Zeit gehabt.
Was an der Geschichte liegt,
die ich euch erzählt habe.
Ich muss mich da
ab und zu ein bisschen mehr überwinden,
als noch vor zwei Jahren.
Aber ich bin immer noch
deutlich fitter, als ich das früher war.
so jetzt kann man machen
ich habe die nicht verwendet die des azure der fox zeug keine ahnung nutzt über ein programmieren
ki unterstützung bezüglich wenig wenig was ich mache ist ich frage ganz gerne mal bei
irgendwelchen jammer falls und so was hier was habe ich da vergessen und so
solche dinger oder auch bei ihnen code wenn sie verbindung mit einer fehler
meldung aber ich muss sagen ich bin nicht so der vibe coder also wenig
so aber was ich euch zeigen wollen wir gerade dabei sind rosa bikes werden das
Rebooted.
Wo ich echt richtig Bock drauf hätte,
ist das neue Background
von Rose, weil
ich zeige euch das mal. Also um genau zu sein, hätte ich
am liebsten das hier.
Das hier hätte ich am liebsten.
Weil
mega nice. Also erstens,
dass die schon fertige Taschen für oben und unten mit
Fitlock Verschluss haben, die direkt zum
Faden, finde ich gut. Wenn man mal was
braucht, ist das nice. Man kann das einfach abmachen,
auch zur seite aber was ich richtig cool finde ist die haben weiß gar nicht ob man das hier
auf dem bild gescheit sieht ja mal wieder gericht das bild davon warum warum man die
kriegt das bild von die haben usb anschluss hier vorne drin die haben usb anschluss hier vorne
drin zum laden von bike computer und sonst was den dynamo den ich hier mit
einem mit einem klick zu schalten kannst oder nicht wenn integrierte integrierte
power bank die du mit damit laden kannst wenn rauf und runter klappbares vorder
und rücklicht da was ich immer dran dran machen muss quasi wenn ich jetzt
licht brauche elektronische schaltung ziemlich gute übersetzung auch berghoch
und ja und stauraum hin unten noch ein bisschen sogar im rohr bin ich finde ich
bin ich habe auch usb an meinem fahrrad usb an meinem fahrrad sieht
folgendermaßen aus ich habe hier so eine kleine tasche da ist eine powerbank
drinnen und wenn ich aufladen will vorne meine sachen hier die ich habe das
handy hier oben drauf oftmals vorne vorne den garmin computer manchmal mich
noch zusätzlich das handy oben drauf dann mache ich hier einfach den das usb
kabel raus und ich habe hier vorne so ein band rum gewickelt da kann man das
ein bisschen reinstecken und dann dran stand stöpseln
benutzt du aktuell wieder dein Auto mehr?
Ich, wie gesagt,
ich fahre eh nicht gerne Auto.
Also ich fahre nicht oft.
Also auch nicht mehr als sonst.
Ja, und da hätte ich richtig
Bock drauf auf das Teil.
Aber ich kaufe
mir kein Fahrrad, weil
ich habe ein ordentliches Fahrrad.
Und die Verbesserungen
sind wirklich minimal eigentlich.
Ich meine,
ich habe ja hier mein
äh
war nicht im
Dings.
Ich hab ja quasi ein Vorgängermodell
davon. Das da.
Mit dem Unterschied,
dass ich gemoddet hab,
hier hinten,
ist es nicht mehr die originale Kassette.
Also hier waren, war 11 bis
34 drauf, ursprünglich.
Und ich
hab 11 bis 42
jetzt drauf. Also was
damit gemeint, es ist 11,
ist das kleinste Zahnrad und
42 ist das größte Zahnrad. Also
42, wie heißt das, Ritzel?
42 Zähne
auf dem Zahnrad.
Ja, das habe ich
ausgetauscht. Es ist zwar offiziell außerhalb
der Spec,
aber es geht.
So,
genau, das habe ich
und irgendwie finde ich
das aber schon sehr
sehr nice, das neue.
Egal.
Zack. Ach ja, und das ist
einmal elf, äh, einmal zwölf.
Und meins ist zweimal elf.
Äh.
Warte.
Machst du Bikepacking-Touren?
Nee, mach ich nicht.
Tagestouren? Naja, also ganz,
also, sag mal so,
ich glaub, das längste, was ich mal gefahren bin, sind knapp
vier Stunden.
also das ist keines geht nicht als tages tages tour durch hast du das über die
arbeit gekauft privat das gekauft um genau zu sein um genau zu sein hat das
eigentlich die gegnerische versicherung bezahlt von derjenigen die mich um
gefahren hat mit meinem alten fahrrad
ja was kam da eigentlich raus nichts das ist durch die haben mittlerweile alles
bezahlt doch die haben sich die haben sich nervig angestellt was ist mit neuem
pc wozu brauche ich einen neuen pc ich habe
einen 13.900k
mit
einer RTX
4090.
Das ist jetzt nicht gerade schlecht.
Wie schaffst du es eigentlich,
dass deine Haut nicht abfällt von der ganzen Sonne
und frische Luft? Naja, in letzter Zeit
war ich ja nicht ganz so aktiv, aber was
nice ist,
was viel besser ist finde ich persönlich als sonnencreme start nicht meine 50 90 jahre
nicht mal 2000 irgendwas euro für eine neue grafikkarte ausgeben einmal mehr so was ich
nice finde uv spray sich wirklich dass die wehr
spray fixe lang für den sub das finde ich weiß
Du sollst das ja auch nicht einatmen.
Das finde ich nice.
Das ist nicht so pappig.
Das ist nicht so pappig wie
Sonnenmilch
und Creme und so.
Sondern das Spray.
Das kann man sich dann...
Das kannst du dir mal auch auf den Hals sprayen und sowas.
Kannst ein bisschen verreiben und gut ist.
Ja, also das finde ich ganz gut.
So.
Alle Updates durch.
Beauty Palace.
Gibt es die überhaupt noch?
Das ist überhaupt nicht mehr so irgendwie
in aller Munde, die ganzen Beauty Channels.
Linux
firmen wir nicht vergessen. Oh, du hast recht. Ich habe aber schon
rebooted, oder?
Also ich habe
das nicht installiert und das Reboot hat einfach funktioniert.
Ja, warum installiere ich das dann
eigentlich?
Brauche ich nicht. Gehe doch ohne.
Boah.
Speed.
So, jetzt soll ich nochmal.
Ich reboote nochmal, schade nix.
Hast du die PewDiePie Videos gesehen?
Ich hab gesehen, dass PewDiePie jetzt Linux verwendet.
Mehr hab ich da nicht gesehen.
Wieso, gibt's da irgendwas?
Irgendwas, was ich verpasst hab?
Welche Arschcreme kannst du für das Rennrad empfehlen?
Ich hab mir mal Arschcreme gekauft.
Offiziell nennt sich das ja nicht Arschcreme,
sondern Chemoi oder so.
Chemi?
Chemoi?
cream oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung
heißt das ja. Habe ich mir gekauft,
habe ich nie ausprobiert, finde ich irgendwie eklig.
PewDiePie hat einen
Ryzen-GPU-Server gebaut.
Okay.
Ach ja, was? Chat, Chat, Chat. Wie geht ihr eigentlich mit dem Windows 10 Support Ende um? Das ist doch jetzt bald, oder?
weil wie ich drauf komme ist
ich habe mich letztens auf der Arbeit
eingeloggt
so ein Remote
Remote Windows
System wo man sich drauf einloggen kann
wenn man mobil unterwegs ist und nur das
Notebook dabei hat und das war
noch Windows 10
habe ich mir gedacht so langsam aber
sicher die kaufen bestimmt
kein Extended Support nur dafür
so langsam aber sicher wird es
nochmal Zeit
von Windows auf Linux gewechselt.
Leute, ich würde auch...
Ups, ich habe gerade mein Mikrofon
gegen die Tastatur gehauen.
Ich würde auch, wenn ich die Möglichkeit hätte,
nur noch Linux verwenden.
Wird aber nichts.
Nee, Battlefield läuft nicht drauf.
Battlefield läuft nicht wegen Secure Boot.
Ja, Sonnenhut auf dem Fahrrad, ein bisschen schwierig
Ne, hab ich extra nicht
Das hab ich gelesen, das war auch wieder so ein Ding, ja
Habt ihr übrigens
Wisst ihr, wo ich richtig Bock drauf hätte?
Es gibt jetzt
Okay, wir sind schon sidetracked
Bevor ich überhaupt angefangen hab, ja
Aber ich hab Zeit, Leute
Wir können heute den ganzen Tag streamen
Ich hab Zeit.
Wisst ihr, wo ich richtig Bock drauf hätte?
Was ich mir echt gerne kaufen würde.
Um mal ein bisschen...
...Pepo Burn Money zu machen.
Um mal ein bisschen den hier zu machen.
Es gibt von Asus...
...A... Asus...
...gibt es jetzt einen 720-Hertz-Monitor.
So
Das ist ein OLED
Also eh, schau mal geil
Das ist ein OLED Display
Der kann entweder
720p mit 720Hz
Oder ich glaube
1440p
mit 540 Hertz.
Das ist doch mal was, oder?
Ey, damit kannst du schon reagieren,
bevor der andere überhaupt was gemacht hat.
720p,
720 Hertz.
Das ist doch nice.
Das ist doch mega.
Für die ganzen CS-Leute und sowas,
die in irgendwelchen
antiken Auflösungen spielen.
Kann ich ein Battlefield spielen mit 20er Tickrate?
Gibt es wirklich einen Unterschied zwischen 540 und 720 Hertz?
Klar, es gibt einen Unterschied von 180 Hertz dazwischen.
Ob man das jetzt merkt?
Naja.
Ich weiß nicht
Ich glaube
Wenn schon, dann nur sehr subtil
Ich bin übrigens immer wieder begeistert
Wie viele Leute darauf anspringen
diesen Gag mit
das menschliche Auge sieht bloß so und so viel FPS
den habe ich über die Jahre auf Twitter
bestimmt schon hundertmal erzählt
und immer kommen wieder irgendwelche Leute
und sagen, ah Max, das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht
ne, ne Leute
das machen wir jetzt nicht
ich habe erstens
letztens erst wieder ein Video gesehen
irgendwie sowas mit
ja, ok, ok, ok, ok
ok
eine sache eine sache die muss ich euch zeigen weil das da keck keck w man wieder c++
ja das habe ich letztes geguckt 31 newbie habits c++ selbst unit
to ditch wir gucken uns nicht das video an macht euch keine gedanken das ist grausam genug hier
Was?
The fuck?
Warum?
Warum ist das alles unterschiedliches Zeug?
Und warum gibt es das überhaupt?
Ja.
Aber die Sprache...
Wenn mich jemand mal nach meiner...
Okay, Leute.
Fragt mich mal nach meinen Top 5 Lieblingsprogrammiersprachen.
Okay, also...
Also meine Top 5 Programmiersprachen, meine 5 Lieblingsprogrammiersprachen...
programmier sprachen sind eindeutig sie schafft das wisst ihr ich mache sehr viel in sich ab
das nächste ist ruby ruby ist so eine geile programmier sprache leider kommt man nicht
mehr dazu irgendwas in ruby zu machen weil ruby voll auf absteigenden ast war die letzten jahre
über auch kein mensch mehr rails verwendet oder sonst was aber ruby ist eine sehr schöne
in sich konsistente schöne programmier sprache ja geht lebt weil es damals in ruby angefangen
wurde er also ruby ruby ist eine super programmier sprache mag ich extrem aber kann man nicht mal viel
drin machen also erster platz die schar zweiter platz auf ruby nächster platz tatsächlich
mittlerweile javascript erstens weil man javascript für nahezu alles verwenden kann und
weil man javascript ähnlich vorbei kommt und weil javascript im vergleich zu dem was das
t plus plus gremium so treibt immer besser geworden ist die letzten jahre javascript
hat immer noch viel historischen kack drin aber das was sie gemacht haben ist
eigentlich ganz gut also javascript muss ich sagen ist top top 3 bei mir immer
noch danach kommt go ich nehme begeistert begeistert von go
war ich war ich noch nie richtig aber ich muss sagen go ist eine
programmiersprache ich finde gar nicht hübsch ja ich finde
immer wenn ich was in go mache gibt es also gibt es fallfall mit gleich sachen
ein wo ich tue meckern könnte aber man kann go nicht absprechen dass es
produktiv ist also ich glaube ich habe in go mehr sachen beendet als in allen
anderen programmiersprachen weil ich meine ich hab da ich habe in go auch nie
richtig große sachen gemacht ja aber mit go kriegst du sachen einfach fertig so
so für irgendwelche kleinen command line tools und sowas ist das beste und so
schlecht ist als programmier sprache auch nicht hast du schon erfahrung mit
bsd so gut wie keine nicht viele ganz wenig also kann ich nichts groß zu sagen
welchem browser ich verwende ich verwende firefox chromium und chrome
tatsächlich mit you blog light bei den chrome browser mittlerweile ja so jetzt
haben meine top 4 programmiersprachen also sie schafft ruby javascript go und
jetzt kommt die fünfte bei der fünften programmiersprache das werdet ihr mir
wahrscheinlich nicht glauben weil ich mag c++ überhaupt nicht ich finde c++ ist von der
entwicklung her und vom aufbau her so ziemlich die schlimmste programmier sprache diese gibt aber
ich würde c++ trotzdem auf den fünf platz setzen weil c++ das ding schlechthin ist
für microcontroller und ich gerne microcontroller bastel und weil durch
seine scheißigkeit c++ irgendwie sogar ein bisschen spaß machen kann dass ich
weiß das ist jetzt irgendwie widersprache widerspruch in sich aber
c++ ist so dumm und kacke das ist schon wieder lustig ist und sich das echt
spaß macht teilweise in diesen blödsinn einzuarbeiten nur um dann wieder
festzustellen okay ich habe fünf weitere punkte für meine niemals enden wollen
die liste warum zirkels kacke ist
manchmal macht strage ja auch spaß ja ich glaube das trifft zwar zirkels
post ganz gut
Ja, das sind meine Top 5 Programmiersprachen.
Ohne jetzt groß drüber nachzudenken.
Wenn ich länger drüber nachdenke,
würde es vielleicht anders aussehen.
So, Banzo, danke schön für den Sub.
Hast du gesehen, dass wir in Go jetzt Memory selbst free machen?
Echt?
Ja? Ne, ne, hab ich nicht gesehen.
Wisst ihr, was für mich Go noch mal eine Nummer geiler machen würde?
Wenn der Interop mit anderen Sprachen besser funktionieren würde.
Also wenn man Go-Sachen mit einem ordentlichen C-Interface ansprechen könnte.
Kann man ja, kann man ja, aber das ist mit sehr viel drumherum verbunden und ist nicht schön.
Was ist deine Meinung? Also hatte ich schon gesagt.
was für projekte hast du in go umgesetzt zum beispiel also eines der sachen die mir jetzt
als erstes einfällt ist zum beispiel das haben wir sogar im stream gemacht habe ich für die
arbeit einen moment wo los tv am heißt das am coupé ja pfeiffer go tool bauen am coupé message
ja da habe ich ein tool gebaut wo man per command line an einen am qp broker nachrichten
publischen kann witzigerweise gab es so was nicht zum damaligen zeitpunkt wo man sich wundert warum
eigentlich nicht einen am cupi das mit deiner kamera ich das ist das erste was
mir jetzt einfällt das habe ich für die arbeit programmiert das haben wir auch
immer noch im glaub ich zumindest die wollen das mal austauschen haben sie
aber glaube ich nie gemacht ich glaube das haben wir immer noch im einsatz das
benutzen wir habe ich container image gebaut mit um automatisiert glaub einmal
nachts eine message in oder messages zu einem message bus zu publischen wo dann
ein anderer service dran hängt der irgendwelche reports generiert wenn er
diese message bekommt normalerweise werden diese reports glaube ich nur
generiert weil man in irgendeinem hersteller eigenen web interface auf den
button klickt aber man kann das über eine message message triggern und das
verschicken wir einmal nächtlich mit meinem command line tool und dafür ist
halt einfach wie gemacht für kleine self content anwendungen so was will ich
heute übrigens auch bastel im stream aber nicht mit go ist das beste also ich
habe in go schon mehr sachen fertig gekriegt wie glaube ich in jeder andere
programmiersprache
Ja, so sieht es aus
So, jetzt machen wir noch einmal Update
Gucken wir nicht, dass Arch by the way
Wieder Pakete geupdatet hat in den 2 Minuten
Wo wir geupdatet haben
Ja, mit Go
Das ist richtig geil, Leute, wenn ihr
Go-Container-Images bauen wollt
gibt es. Richtig cooles
Projekt.
Wo ich jetzt vergessen habe, wie es heißt.
Ich meine nicht Distroless. Distroless gibt es auch.
Das ist auch gut. Da kommen auch kleine
Container-Images raus.
Aber ich habe letztens noch ein anderes
Projekt gefunden.
Irgendwas mit U. Kann das sein?
Ah, ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt.
Ne, das meine ich nicht.
ist das denn so richtig kleine nice base images weil sie nicht mehr
diese nenne nix explizit für go minimalistischen
wolfi was nicht glaube ich keine ahnung vergessen wie das heißt
Ja, egal
Komme ich jetzt nicht drauf
Aber das hier ist auch nice
Ich habe letztes Jahr mal auf der Arbeit
Was präsentiert auf einer Abteilungsversammlung
Und da habe ich unter anderem gezeigt
Wie man ein Distroless
Docker-Container baut
Der dann versus ein Ubuntu-Container
Nur 11 MB groß ist mit einem Go-Binary
Achso, das ist ein weiteres Ding
Was ich in Go programmiert habe
Ich habe einen Custom Prometheus-Exporter
für uns auf der arbeit gebaut wir haben das software bei uns laufen die block chain gedöns
macht die hat zwar selbst ein abbekennt aber das kannst du ja nicht also da hast ja keine
metriken nur weil du ein abbekennt hast du das abfragen kannst so habe ich ein prometheus
exporter gebaut der über dieses über diese die dies nur auf localhost
verfügbar von diesem service und der das programm fragt quasi bei der lokalen api
bei informationen ab zum beispiel letzter gesünder blog letzter times
und solche geschichten und stellt das dann als prometheus metriken und das
Slashmetrics bereit. Und die
crawlen wir dann von einem Prometheus aus
und können das auswerten. Da sieht man dann
richtig schön, ob unsere Blockchain
Sachen in Sync sind oder nicht.
Wäre so von Haus aus
nicht möglich gewesen. Und für sowas
ist Go halt geil. Das Ding habe ich
gebaut mit einem Distroless
Container Image. Das war dann am Ende
glaube ich 11 MB oder sowas.
Und ein Ubuntu Image ist halt 500 MB.
Man kann auch
Alpine nehmen oder irgendwas anderes, aber
das ist schon sehr klein gewesen. Und das Schöne ist
halt dass das mit go wunderbar funktioniert weil go ist halt so klein
und selbst content ich mein goal ist jetzt nicht eine
static rust application ist kleiner als goja bei go ist ja noch viel runtime
zeug und so dabei aber go hat halt nix an abhängigkeiten
jeder andere programmier sprache die mir so einfällt hat abhängigkeiten und sei
es zu geliebten und sobald du das hast hast du wieder ganz andere probleme
das ist zum beispiel probleme du baust hast du baust das binary auf dem
aktuellen archlinux willst aber auf dem ubuntu 2004 laufen lassen kannst du aber
nicht weil geliebt blablub mismatch dafür ist halt einfach nice go kannst du ein binary bauen
und das ist rückwärts kompatibel bis zu linux kernel 2 632 glaube ich das ist das ist für
solche kleinen sachen halt einfach nur top wie machst du das mit dem notex
partner fragst du die lokale api dann erst ab wenn der get request reinkommt
so dass die daten wirklich sehr aktuell sind oder hast du im go programm eine
routine welche perioden abfragt dann lokal speichern so dass wenn die get
request reinkommen einfach der klub ja so mache ich das ich frage alle vor
die fünf sekunden oder so die api ab
passen wir auf ich glaube wir haben das doch irgendwo noch block chain monitor
champ chat da ist es doch noch der block chain monitor champ haben wir das
vielleicht aber das vielleicht in go land noch drin da habe ich ein bisschen
sind tags highlighting so wo sind meine settings hin
meine settings hinweg warum skip open
repos lock chain monitor champ trust katschi bass
Ja, Moment, das ist das Alte.
Da haben wir noch Polygon-Scan abgefragt.
Ja, das brauchen wir nicht.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Okay, da habe ich nur geguckt, wie die Prometheus-API funktioniert.
Das, nee.
Dann können wir das nicht nehmen dafür.
Das war quasi nur Beispiele an.
Ja, aber ich mach so, wie du das geschrieben hast.
Ich frag da alle paar Sekunden die lokale API ab.
Also das wird als Sidecar injected in den eigentlichen Service-Pod.
dann laufen dann im Endeffekt dort
zwei Container
in dem Pod, nämlich die eigentliche
Blockchain Software und
der Prometheus Exporter
und nachdem ja die API von
der Blockchain Software nur auf Localhost
verfügbar ist
und Localhost ist ja geshared
zwischen allen Containern in einem Pod
fragt er da alle 5 Sekunden ab
fragt ab, der fragt
ja nicht viel ab, der fragt den
letzten gesunken block ab errechnet sich da oder den timestamp fragte glaube ich
noch ab und er rechnet sich dann dennoch daraus irgendwie das alter des blogs so
da stellt der element effekt nur drei oder 44 klopp glaubt die transaktionen
die letzten block exportiert da auch noch 44 metriken und alle fünf sekunden
mal irgendwie so ein zwei requests juckt ja nicht wie oft prometheus ab also der
promit der node exporter fragt glaube ich alle fünf sekunden sind alle zwei
sekunden oder alle fünf sekunden wo ich abfrage
das macht nicht so viel traffic also wenn du jetzt natürlich ein exporter
wenn du jetzt natürlich da irgendwie keine ahnung 500 500 request machen
musst, dann würde ich es nicht unbedingt
alle zwei oder fünf Sekunden machen.
Aber mal,
aber alle fünf Sekunden mal drei, vier
Requests? Pff.
Das ist ja nix. Das wirst du wahrscheinlich auch wegen einem
CPU-Graf noch nicht mal sehen,
dass das überhaupt stattfindet.
Es sei denn, das sind halt mega expensive
API-Abfragen.
Also wenn das irgendeine API-Abfrage ist, wo das dann erstmal
für 15 Sekunden hängt, bis es eine Antwort
gibt, dann würde ich das auch nicht
alle fünf Sekunden abfragen.
Also ich glaube, ich habe es entweder alle 2 oder alle 5 Sekunden gemacht.
Und die Werte merkt er sich halt im RAM, der Exporter.
Weil wenn das nächste Mal neu gestartet wird, fragt er einfach wieder neu ab.
Und so würde ich es auch machen, weil umgedreht würde er dann quasi der Prometheus hängen beim Abfragen, bis er eine Antwort kriegt.
Das finde ich nicht so schön.
Achso, wie oft der Collector den Exporter abfragt
Ach nee, das ist seltener
Das ist selten, das weiß ich gar nicht
5 Minuten oder so?
30 Sekunden
Ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung
An das Trinken erinnern, ja
Weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung
Also ich würde mal auf 5 Minuten tippen
Weil das sehr nach Default klingt
wahrscheinlich fünf minuten ja ich lege mal ein repo an für heute und zwar den
keck keck weh champ den wollte ich schon immer haben will immer haben
natürlich gibt es den ordner fast schon übrigens vor allem champ keck weh nebenbei
ist es nicht schön dass mittlerweile nicht nur emojis in dem terminal gehen sondern auch wirklich
farbige bildchen und sowas doch nice oder also es ist ja eigentlich keine farbigen bild ist
es einfach nur asky asky text aber halt es geht halt nur weil true color support im
terminal letztendlich ist es ja es ist ja das bildchen ja ne aber keine ahnung fünf minuten
reicht doch eigentlich oder also für metriken finde ich reicht fünf minuten auf jeden fall
wenn du damit dann irgendwelche möglichst zeitkritischen alerts machen
willst dann würde ich vielleicht ein bisschen schneller abfragen wann
umstieg auf warum habe ich irgendwas mit drei verpasst ist die drei die picket
oder was
es existiert ja auch noch das kitty image protokoll es existiert auch dass
es existiert auch das item 2 image protokoll
damit kann man im terminal zum beispiel so was hier abspielen
guck mal gif animation im terminal ist es nicht leis ich würde sagen das ist
Das ist schon echt nah an der Grenze zu Pog.
So, gehen wir mal hier hin.
Also, was ich heute eigentlich mal ausprobieren wollte, ist folgendes.
sofern ich das sofern ich das geistig hinkriege weil eins muss ich sagen ich habe ja vorhin
erzählt dass ich aktuellen papieren nehme und so ist bisschen ein bisschen verwirrt im kopf
beziehungsweise wird es das falsche wort bisschen konzentrationsprobleme hat man da schon
Benebelt.
Ja, nee, benebelt ist das falsche Wort.
Eher war es ein bisschen Probleme, sich zu konzentrieren.
Aber das...
An sich muss ich sagen, vertrage ich die Pillen echt ganz gut.
Ja und?
Wenn es so wäre, im Jahr 2025 ist das doch alles kein Problem mehr.
Außerdem, woher weißt du denn, ob ich es nicht schon bin?
Kann doch alles sein.
Ja, genau so sieht es aus.
So, also, was ich eigentlich heute vorhat, ist folgendes.
Ich habe gelesen...
Valorant's too on the air, bloß aufhören.
Ich wollte ein paar Sachen ausprobieren.
Also, ich versuche mal dann.
also ich will dort net anwendung machen was ziemlich bescheuert das wort ist für
einfach ganz normal kompilieren sowie das andere programmiersprachen auch machen was
was was wie was wie moment ich verstehe nicht den bezug zu irgendwas gerade
was ist das anti cheat detection
ich verstehe nicht was ist das
weil max knorr nicht mag ja gut kde mag ich aber auch nicht das ist ja das ding
oder ich mag kein linux desktop das einzige was für mich halbwegs
erträglich ist es die drei auch guck mal der pippo ist gerade am kacken
Stripes, danke für den Sub.
So, wie gesagt,
ja, Concentration und so.
Also,
Cinnamon, ja, Cinnamon
geht noch, das stimmt.
Also, ich will eine .NET IoT Anwendung
machen, die ein Embedded
Webseite
Webseite GUI
enthält. So.
Mit Swellkit.
Und das Ganze per Docker-Bild.
So. Weil...
Also. Ich hab nämlich ein paar Sachen
gelesen.
Wieso kein Sway?
Ja, weil Sway Wayland ist.
Und Wayland funktioniert nicht richtig
in VMware.
Bist du eigentlich mittlerweile bei
Google, yonder Boy?
Wolltest du dich nicht mal
irgendwie vor drei Jahren da bewerben?
oder hat es nicht geklappt?
Du hast doch mal erzählt,
du wolltest dich dort bewerben oder irgendwas.
Oh, da habe ich das falsch im Kopf.
Würde mich mal interessieren,
ob das geklappt hat.
Ach so, du, aber,
dann habe ich es falsch im Kopf.
Ich hatte irgendwie im Kopf,
wir waren bei ihnen so einem bei irgendeinem stellenanzeigen stream und
du sagst wollte ich da bewährt habe ich falsch im kopf dann vergisst es
so
genau also dass das das euch ja und zwei kann ich nicht verwenden weil weyland
und Wayland nicht richtig funktioniert in der VM.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile so ein bisschen Hype um Hyperland.
Das heißt, die ganzen coolen Leute verwenden ja Hyperland unter Wayland.
Ich habe es mal vor einem Jahr oder so ausprobiert,
in der VM zum Laufen zu bringen und das ging.
aber immer wenn ich was geöffnet hab
wie beispielsweise ein Browser oder so ist es dann gefreezed
also es hat nicht richtig funktioniert
ist das nicht
die
von dem
von dem Ruby on Rails Erfinder
dass
die Config
ja ist es
ja
äh okay
But why?
YouTube please!
YouTube!
Chat geht das Stream noch oder ist das einfach mein Internet im Arsch?
Okay, geht wieder. Nice.
Anti-Adblock-Maßnahmen, ja.
Es ist schon nervig geworden,
das Internet.
Das Internet von heute,
so als Opa gesprochen,
es ist schon nervig geworden.
Halten dich wirklich nur ein paar Games mit...
Ja, ja, ja, ja,
ihr also nicht mich hält auch ein bisschen mein streaming und youtube
videoschneiden und thumbnails erstellen und so davon ab weil ich zu faul bin
mich an neue sachen zu gewöhnen und gerade bei obs und streaming und so bin
ich mir nicht so sicher wie gut das wie gut das funst und dann
bleiben natürlich noch games mit anti cheater
du kannst du kannst du verwenden ja hier das ding
die block origin light
Aber die Games sind natürlich ein Killer-Kriterium da, das geht halt sonst nicht.
Was kann der Light noch?
Wärmung blocken.
Aber nicht mal so gut wie das originale Block Origin.
Kann jeder machen was er will.
Manche Leute stehen auch auf Opera GX und so Zeug.
Kennt ihr eigentlich einen Browser, der ein ordentliches VPN integriert hat, wo man auswählen kann, wo man rauskommen will?
Ich frage aus folgendem Grund, weil ich möchte ab und zu mal Radsport gucken.
Und das ist immer ein richtiger Krampf, dort einen Stream zu bekommen.
Das ist immer ein richtiger Krampf, da was zu bekommen.
Gibt es das überhaupt noch?
Haben die noch Live-Coverage?
Achso, ja gut.
Ich habe eigentlich auch nicht vor,
ein Abo für abzuschließen, muss ich auch noch sagen.
Das ist ja gerade die Spanien-Rundfahrt.
da wollte ich ein paar etappen gucken aber es ist echt unglaublich schwierig
da eine ordentliche live stream zu kommen
wenn man nicht gerade irgendwie den discovery plus abo oder sowas abschließt
ja das wie gesagt ich weiß ja was man machen kann
ich wollte mir einfach auch mal wieder vm anlegen und dann kann ich ja ein
browser über ist das h tunnel das ist auch kein ding also ich meine jetzt
nicht den browser tunnel sondern den sox proxy tunneln und dann meinen browser
darauf einstellen ist funzt ja auch aber ich habe gedacht vielleicht gibt es
irgendwas so out of the box browser wo schon vpn dabei ist wo man dann aus
wählen kann wo man rauskommen will
na gut also das hatte ich eigentlich vor heute ich wollte dort also ja genau
jetzt kommen sie konzentrations progress also warum ich da eigentlich drauf
gekommen bin ist folgendes ich habe mir gedacht desktop ui technologien sind ja
alle kacke gibt ja nichts gescheites selbst microsoft unter windows kriegt
ja nichts gescheites hin für desktop ui und das was es gibt ist mist und das
beste was es gibt ist auch mist weil das ist elektron das funktioniert überall
aber ist im prinzip ja auch nur den browser gerappt also habe ich mir
gedacht wenn man nicht irgendwelche native integration braucht wie hier ich
will unten in der leiste was anzeigen sondern sondern man will einfach nur
einen ui um für seine anwendung ein paar settings anklicken zu können oder
irgendwelche status sachen oder so warum macht man nicht einfach den web server
in seine anwendung und lässt dann ein browser fenster aufgehen mit einer
embedded webseite das ist ja im endeffekt bisschen wie
elektron nur dass es halt ein eigenes browser fenster ist und bei der
gelegenheit ist mir eingefallen dass welt geht jetzt ein nur einen neuen
deploy mode hat habe ich nämlich gelesen bild embedded oder so hieß das glaube
wenn ich jetzt finden würde
ja das ist immer so geht's los ich finde schon gar nicht mehr
die haben zumindest einen neuen bild modus welt geht ich guck mal ob ich dann youtube
video zu finden wie hieß das denn die haben einen neuen bild da kann es welt
kit alles entdecken in eine index html
und das ist halt extrem nice gerade wenn man beispielsweise auch einen micro
controller hat von dem man ein web frontend ausliefern will und das wollte
ich mal ausprobieren da habe ich mir gedacht wenn man schon das gerade mal
Wenn man das schon mal ausprobiert ins Weltkit, dann können wir doch auch gleich mal ausprobieren, das in eine .NET Anwendung zu embedden, die wir IoT kompilieren, dass wir dann quasi eine self-contained .NET Anwendung kriegen mit einem Webinterface.
und das Ganze würde ich im Docker-Container bauen.
Da können wir das nämlich auf Ubuntu 18.04 bauen.
Ubuntu 18.04 hat den Vorteil,
dass es die älteste supportete Version ist,
von GLIB-C, die .NET aktuell noch unterstützt.
Und damit laufen dann quasi unsere Binaries
auf allen Linux-Systemen der letzten 8 Jahre.
Naja, 7,5 Jahre.
so das ist das ist gar nichts großes umfangreiches ich muss es aber erst
nochmal finden
Wie ist das?
Ein Svelte-Kit?
Ähm, self-contained.
Ähm.
Ja.
Index HTML.
Da gab es doch sogar mal ein GitHub-Issue zu.
How to output build a single HTML-File.
Okay.
der grau vor flow in line das suche ich nicht in ich bild bandels strategy muss
ich suchen dann ist das das richtige okay aber ein
bild weil man macht der npm bild das meine ich das ist nämlich neu jetzt
da kann man jetzt nämlich sagen bundle strategy single inline genau inline
wollen wir haben da erstellt nämlich das weltkit eine index html in der alles
drin ist komplett alles javascript was man braucht und komplett alles css was
man braucht und natürlich auch komplett html was man braucht und man kann
während der entwicklungszeit aber trotzdem ganz normales weltkit verwenden
und das finde ich sehr nice das wollte ich mal ausprobieren und das index html
dann im bett in der dotnet anwendung die das ganze über einen web server
raushaut was man das quasi als config für eine anwendung verwenden könnte ja
ich quasi nach html kompiliert da würde ich sagen da fangen wir doch mit das
weltgeschichte an wir machen mal hier machen wir mal hier
einen keine ahnung wir machen mal ein bild das brauche höchstwahrscheinlich
eben oder oder output drin ist aber irgendwie das blöd blöd sie nennen was
mal da kommt die dort net anwendung rein ja und hier mk dir keine ahnung irgendwie
so wie legt man denn mittlerweile eines welt kit anwendung an das hat sich doch
auch 50 mal geändert gibt es dann auch ein beispiel für getting started tutorial tutorial
tutorial okay gibt das herr tut das muss jetzt mal kurz auf dem zweiten bildschirm gucken
den gibt's noch
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, wie ich da gerade drauf gekommen bin.
Hier, npx sv create.
Punkt. Soll ich machen.
Okay.
Npx. Warum ist npx nicht mal drauf?
Ah!
Leute, wisst ihr, warum npx nicht mal drauf ist?
Wer hat aufgepasst?
Ich habe vorher Notch-ASD installiert.
Daran könnte es vielleicht liegen.
Äh, ist NPX was eigenes?
Oder, nee, NPM.
Bei NPM ist das dabei.
Was war das da oben?
Ist jetzt npx drauf?
Need to install following dependencies. Yes.
Which template would you like? SvelteKit-Demo, SvelteKit-Minimal. Minimal wollen wir haben.
TypeScript.
Damit fangen wir gar nicht erst an hier.
No. Was wollen wir sonst noch haben?
Pretty, ja? Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das wollen wir alles nicht.
Äh.
war brauche ich das ich dachte okay das ist nicht so ganz funktion weil früher
konnte man adapter static machen aber ich glaube das braucht man gar nicht mehr
jetzt mit diesem neuen bundle gut dann machen wir es ist gerade wie
wir wählen mal da nix von aus.
Which package manager
you want to install dependencies with?
PNPM.
Ach komm, wir machen NPM und gut ist.
So.
Da sind wir.
Und jetzt machen wir NPM run open.
Tag.
Willkommen zu SvelteKit.
Perfekt.
Bei der Webseite werden wir jetzt gar nichts großartig machen.
das ist ja als demo webseite vollkommen okay jetzt machen wir mal npm npm run
bild was passiert denn dann bild da passiert gar nichts
ach doch hier das weltkit okay da ist okay da ist aber die ganze anwendung
unterschiedliche files das war nicht so und jetzt mal gucken wie das hier funzt
mit mit dieser mit dieser geschichte bundles strategy wir machen jetzt mal
den fettmuff leute
Wollen wir mal Chat-GPD fragen?
Obster, how to use
Import Adapter Static
Bundle Strategy Inline
Meint ihr, das stimmt so?
Ich such mal so
example single das gab es doch überhaupt nicht oder
Ach, Single, gell?
Ach, Single war, wo es einen extra JavaScript-File
und einen extra CSS-File gab, gell?
Ja.
Äh.
gibt es jetzt ein example für ok
set output bahn strategy gleich in landset router type hash
page und vg
documentation updates
okay das ist wieder extrem feifert wie man das macht
My
Confusion have been resolved
Chat, ist bei euch die Confusion
resolved?
Also bei mir
ist die Confusion noch da
Wie das jetzt eigentlich
funktioniert
Also wir machen das Ganze mal in Visual Studio Code
auf, das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht verkehrt
Ja, ja, trust, wir trusten
so jetzt müssen wir in die welt konflikt so adapter auto ist wahrscheinlich verkehrt
aha
was ich will einfach nur ein beispiel haben
ich will kein tool was das für mich macht ich will einfach nur ein beispiel
Beispiel.
What the fuck?
Aha.
Hä?
Okay, das scheint
Pfeiffer zu sein. Wollen wir mal Chat-GPT
glauben, ob das stimmt?
Ich mache jetzt einfach mal hier
Output, bin Bundle-Strategy-Inline
und dann gucke ich mal, was passiert.
Output. Warte mal, wo muss das jetzt hin?
Kit.
Output.
output und dann das da und jetzt bundles strategy in line ok was passiert jetzt wenn ich ein bild
macht gar nichts konnte man wie gibt man wie gibt man denn hier überhaupt dass
das das directory an wohin es bilden soll
an ich würde es vielleicht abgucken von irgendwas
irgendwo abgucken wo ich schon mal gemacht
hallo so so
ähm
oder war das Bild?
Out, out, dear.
Die Fall ist Pumps Weltkid.
Achso, okay.
Also das heißt,
das war schon richtig.
NPM Run Build.
Moment.
Achso, ne.
Äh, was?
Cannot find base config file.
Was?
Ich...
Stimmt, ich hab das Verzeichnis gelöscht.
Warum?
Ich check.
Okay, Svelte Kit.
Hier Output.
Ja, aber...
Aber hier ist doch jetzt mehr...
Guck mal, hier ist so viel Zeug drin.
Das ist doch jetzt mehr als eine Single-HTML-Seite, oder?
Hm.
Jetzt was gucken.
Hä?
Ich check nämlich noch Funst.
Okay, weißt du was?
Ich.
Nee, das macht überhaupt kein...
Das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht.
was. Guck mal, ChatGPT
halluziniert hier wieder krasses
Zeug zusammen. BundleStrategy
schreibt da in Prerender rein.
Das muss überhaupt nicht in Prerender, sondern in Output.
Also das ist schon mal Blödsinn.
Brauche ich jetzt den Static Adapter
immer noch?
Moment, das hatten wir schon.
Import Adapter from Svelte.
Ja, muss man das mit dem Static Adapter machen?
Okay, hier.
Hier gibt es ein Beispiel.
Billing portable Web-Apps
with strategy-Herschule.
Okay. Sehr gut.
Config.
Kit.
Adapter.
Ich mach das jetzt einfach mal.
Das war es schon?
Making the Hash Router work.
We add this key to the
Config Kit
Router.
Also quasi hier.
Router type hash. Was auch immer. Ja das machen wir jetzt nicht. Putting it all together.
Aber mit static macht er hier nichts. Ach doch! Hat er vielleicht... Hat er vielleicht hier ein
beispiel und wir gucken jetzt einfach mal durch das video das ist ja wieder
komplizierter als ich das gedacht habe okay was für ein adapter verwendet er
denn
war das wichtigste zeigt er nicht
er zeige ich ob es ist ein adapter ist geil als beste
okay die machen alles der tiger adapter das mache ich jetzt auch import adapter
static guter type hash bei der inline adapter fallback index html was
brauche wahrscheinlich nicht ok npm an jetzt muss ich den statik adapter noch
installieren npm static bild index html
warum habe ich ein ordner was bild heißt nummer blöde frage wo kommt der ordner
her von mir ist er nicht der hatte immer ist angelegt ich dachte da geht ab und
zweck gut soll mir recht sein so das heißt im endeffekt ich habe jetzt hier
eine index html warum habe ich dann noch noch ein anders
co-app was macht es da das braucht man gar nicht mehr oder im index html
Alright.
Alles klar, Leute.
Keg JavaScript.
Okay, schauen wir mal, ob es funktioniert.
Chrome.
Index HTML.
Funst.
Was nicht Funst ist die Schriftart.
Aber das ist nicht weiter wild.
Schlägt irgendwas fehl?
Ne, der will wirklich sonst nix.
sonst nichts laden okay das war's das von store okay gut also im prinzip kann man
alles löschen hier drin außer was steht in der robots drin im prinzip kann man
alles löschen außer die index html okay das war tatsächlich relativ easy
das heißt wir haben jetzt der embedded okay da können wir jetzt in den mist
reinschreiben hier aber nochmal def index habe ich wo die fonds hierher
komm, lädt der irgendwelche Fonts runter?
Alter, what?
Keine Ahnung, wo der Font überhaupt herkommt.
Wir machen jetzt hier in
Source Roots
Page
Page.
Jetzt muss ich irgendein Default.
Moment, ich habe das Welt nicht installiert.
Warte mal.
Profile.
Web muss ich umschalten.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich das überhaupt installiert habe.
So, da schreiben wir jetzt irgendeinen Mist rein.
A1, Omegalul Embedded Website.
Beste.
Was hat er für Schmerzen damit?
Das ist beste Website überhaupt.
die wollte schon immer jeder mal haben gut und das heißt wenn ich das jetzt baue aber das nochmal
npm run bild kriege ich ein bild index html chrome bild index html ja ja das ist die gleiche
schriftart wenn man es groß macht ok passt also die die die webseite haben wir schon mal ich
meine da könnten jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr drauf machen aber wozu was trinken
so jetzt haben wir die welt geschichte jetzt kommt die große preisfrage was machen wir als
nächstes wir machen unser docker file würde ich sagen code docker file das werde ich mir jetzt
mal klauen ja das werde ich mir jetzt mal klauen und zwar vom vm champ da haben wir doch ein docker
file wo man ein bisschen was von uns abgucken können docker file from cento s7 ne cento s7
vielleicht nicht. Also ich meine, wir müssen ja zwei
Sachen bauen. Wir müssen
einmal ein
Svelte-Anwendung bauen
und wir müssen eine
.NET-Anwendung bauen. Das heißt,
wir müssen
ein, also müssen
nicht, können ein
Multistage-Bild machen.
Da können wir nämlich, gibt es ein offizielles
Svelte-Kit-Image?
Das wäre cool.
gibt es ein offizielles weltkrieg im
wahrscheinlich nicht
die benutzer ein dann ist auch egal da
kann man das auch alles unter ubuntu
1804 machen
ok von ubuntu wir müssen erstmal gucken
.NET Minimum Requirement Ubuntu oder Debian oder sowas.
GitHub.
Die haben nämlich immer so eine Readme-Datei.
System Requirements.
Äh.
Wo steht denn...
...was die brauchen?
Das ist immer...
...dass der Scheiß immer so schwierig zu finden ist, man.
Aber kannst du nicht die neueste Ubuntu-Version nehmen,
wenn das eh im Docker-Container am Ende ist?
Nee, kann ich nicht, weil...
Das Ding ist, wenn du ein Self-Contained-AOT-Binary baust mit .NET, dann linkt das gegen die GLIB-C-Version auf dem System, auf dem du das baust.
Also im Prinzip das gleiche Problem, was alle Programmiersprachen außer Go haben.
Und wenn du das auf einem ganz neuen System baust und auf einem alten System verwenden willst, sagt der GLIB-C-Mismatch.
Ich will ja das Binary nicht im Docker-Container haben.
Ich will das im Docker-Container bauen und das Binary dann draußen außerhalb vom Docker-Container benutzen.
Ich will ja kein Container-Image bauen.
Das ist nicht das Ziel.
Ich will eine Anwendung bauen.
Und das Binary dann rausholen am Ende.
Daniel Lull, danke für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscriptions.
Das ist ja...
Nice.
also wisst ihr was suchmaschinen sachen teilweise echt schon richtig
die feining liebste tage den plan das suche ich genau
hier
Hä?
Ich hab mal Kagi getestet.
Weiß ich nicht, was das ist.
Okay, man findet mal wieder nix.
supported os ja
supported os das such ich
master main für 10
supported os nicht jason
Linux dem jan 13 12
Ubuntu was die gehen nur noch bis
wirklich
Das ist aber schwach
Irgendwie hätte ich gedacht die machen 1804 wie sah es dann wie sahen das noch bei dort 9 aus
22 echt gehen die nicht mehr länger zurück das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren wartet mal doch ran
ja hier bla bla bla bla kommt man zu 18.04
ich habe das doch hier in dem docker fall drinnen genau hier wird dann installiert
das muss ich mal ausprobieren ob man dort nicht wirklich nicht mal verwenden kann unter
ubuntu 1804 du willst auf 20 und viel für ein projekt das läuft hast du auch
dort erzählen oder was oder oder 9 jetzt komisch dass normalerweise unterstützen
die immer weil ich glaube 1804 ist doch sogar noch extended support oder
ja guck mal hier
legacy support jetzt sogar sogar 16 04 ist läuft noch
da hätte ich gedacht dass die längere zeug supporten wir probieren das jetzt mal aus
hier curl. Gucken wir mal ob das funzt. Ja gut also nur weil man es installieren kann heißt
ja nicht dass es funktioniert. CD, Temp, MKDia, Kekl.
Achso.
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal, das auszuschalten?
Hier.
Ja.
Invariant.
Export.
Kunst doch alles noch hier geht doch alles unter unter 1804 noch
dann lassen wir mal das in hello world dort dort bauen guck mal ob das noch funktioniert
drei stunden später warum auch nicht
Moment, ah, ich brauche, okay
Build
Ne, Moment
Das ist Arch Linux, oder?
Äh, Debian Build Essentials
Wie heißt das Package dort?
Ach, Build Essential heißt das
Compiler genügend.
Und Perl. MonkaS.
Chat, macht noch irgendeiner von euch
was mit Perl?
Ich wünschte euch ja nicht.
Guck mal, es hat funktioniert.
Wir können ohne Probleme
Huns, wir können ohne Probleme
unter 1804 bilden.
Wollen wir mal ausprobieren, ob wir auch unter 1604
bilden können?
machen wir mal doch ran weil ich meine das reicht dann wirklich jetzt echt also 16 04
so alt muss das ganze nicht sein machen wir machen wir jetzt einfach geht da schnell werden
wir die befehle hier also ab update habt install curl und bild ist sensuell ob das
16 04 funktioniert weil ich mein dann haben wir zehn jahre zehn jahre alte
linux wo unser zeug drauf läuft so das würde ich mal behaupten reicht
einmal runterladen installieren ging schon mal im kardia keckel.net.net new
console ok 16 04 von uns nicht mehr 1804 und ja dann können wir unser docker
file eigentlich auf 1804 stellen aber das noch mal ubuntu 1804 es bild work
und directory slash app so also das mal kurz überlegen docker file wir wollen
als erstes unsere der was wollen wir machen wir wollen als erstes unsere
.NET Anwendung bauen und dann wollen wir
unsere Svelte Anwendung, ne
umgedreht, wir wollen erst unsere Svelte
Anwendung bauen und dann unsere .NET
Anwendung, das heißt wir brauchen jetzt erstmal
Node.js
brauchen wir das? Ne, brauchen wir nicht
wir benutzen, wir machen ein Multistage Bild
Node.js
Docker Image, es gibt doch bestimmt ein offizielles
Node.js Docker Image, oder?
Ja
Alpine, gibt es das vielleicht
auch nicht auf Alpine, Bullseye
da ist es doch aber das normal
kann man da
gerne das hier copy pasten
warum wir doch erstmal unsere
also hier form jetzt wahrscheinlich note ist es noch so not j s
ist das jemand laut ist es noch doppelpunkt version
bild
bild.js
so.
Ja, bild.ui.
Nehmen wir es mal irgendwie so.
Ähm, genau.
So, run.
Da ist ja noch kein Svelte-Kill-Install.
Was ist denn da drin in so einem Node-Imitator?
Das ist npm und gedönst ist ja da alles drin.
Das heißt, wenn ich
jetzt das da reinkopiere,
copy,
dann kann ich
das da drin doch eigentlich schon
bilden
also wir machen copy
gui
nach
ja
keine Ahnung
da ist doch egal
ach ne ich will ja
du hast recht moment moment
das ist ja wieder Trick 17
eine javascript anwendungen bauen zu lassen genau ist dann ein docker ignore
file drin kein docker ignore ein git ignore file gut das schon mal gut dass
ein stimmt ich will ja gar nicht das komplette ding da rein kopieren wie
macht man das jetzt schreibt
ja genau das will er dort modul so das ganze zeug will ich ja gar nicht rein
kopieren ja also im prinzip brauche ich hier ja das ist halt nicht schön aber
kann ja machen also wir brauchen den für stocker file
bild brauche nicht geht ich noch brauche nicht jazz konflikt modus brauche nicht
npm log nicht so ausbauen statik brauche nicht das brauchen wir nicht das war also
diese files brauchen wir so copy
was sind docker ignore file ja aber so bist du aber so muss es doch eigentlich
auch funsten
und das jetzt hier in den container rein
Das müsste doch so zu tun. Probieren wir das doch mal aus.
Docker build... äh... was? Not found. Achso, ja. Not found, weil GUI slash davor muss.
Ah!
Was macht er da eigentlich gerade?
dass ich immer noch das Image ziehen.
Okay, ja, das hat funktioniert.
Sehr gut. Exzellent.
Können wir nicht sagen, irgendwie run
mkdir slash
app oder so
oder slash
slash build
und wir kopieren das
nach slash build. Wäre das halt irgendwie
sinniger doch so weil dann dann können wir jetzt nämlich sagen run npm run
bild punkt oder braucht man das überhaupt
brauchen wir nicht npm run bild mehr prominent warum ach so moment cd
Ach, npm install muss ich vorher noch machen, gell?
npm install
Sowas hier?
Was will das von mir?
Ideal Tree Already Exists.
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
Das darf schon Slash Build heißen.
Ist der vielleicht nicht im
Ordner drin?
Ja.
Genau.
Der, ich muss, ach, deswegen
hab ich da oben Worktree gesagt.
Work.
Wie ist das?
Dear. Slash Bild.
Ach so.
Es hatte schon Sinn, was ich da mal
ursprünglich gemacht hab.
Pass mal auf, jetzt folgt...
Ja, hä?
Hä?
Ah, kann es sein, dass ich hier Punkt Sternchen oder so machen muss?
Muss ich das?
Warte mal.
Docker Copy Recursive.
Genau, ich muss da einen Slash hinten dran machen noch, ne?
Oder nicht?
ja habe ich doch okay brand lsla slash bild
gibt es wieder jetzt hier aus wann das passt dass man immer mal so simple zeug daran rum hängt
ok ist ja was und jetzt
locker ran
jetzt gehen wir da einfach mal rein als es das hier ist ja guck mal
da gibt es einfach kein src okay es gibt einfach nicht aber kein bock und warum nicht
warum gibt es da alles warum gibt es ein lip den lip was ich gar nicht
jetzt bin ich echt verwirrt was macht das ding da
moment
der kopiert jetzt dass da rein das will ich doch nicht der soll das verzeichnis kopieren
Ja, aber da hatte ich es doch die ganze Zeit richtig.
Da hatte ich es doch vorher die ganze Zeit richtig.
Ne, was?
Was?
Nee, GUI kopieren will ich nicht.
Muss ich vielleicht das mit dem Punkt weg machen?
Jetzt bin ich ja echt gerade ein bisschen planlos.
Muss ich das im zweiten Step machen?
Selfmadeice, danke schön für den Sub.
ok ich mache das mit dem source mal weg hier
opi source nach slash bild slash
kipps ab direkt restructure ja
da kommen wir echt vor der letzte kaknup vorgrad
copy der eckte using was
ach so du hast recht ja das kann ich das kann ich in dem fall in dem fall könnte ich das so machen
Da müssen wir auch nochmal einen Slash hinten dran machen.
Ja, stimmt. Das müsste funktionieren.
Das müsste funktionieren.
Ja, okay. Nice.
Bild.
ja sehr schön bei es
an mpn bild sondern jetzt haben wir da einen bild ordner drin gut so und jetzt können wir sagen copy
copy wir wollen ja keinen kein release image machen jetzt brauchen wir was wo man dort nett
bilden kann also das ist jetzt fertig das hat er jetzt gebaut und jetzt war
man ubuntu bild bild heißt das wirkt ihr gibt es auch wieder bild so da müssen wir
das mal dort nett installieren
wobei es gibt doch moment moment moment an die offiziellen die offiziellen
internet images sind aber zu neu
Und vorher brauchen wir noch run apt update run apt install build essential curl-
würde sonst nach dem npm install erst kopieren
dass die da hast du recht das ist das ist generell ziemlich clever
stimmt stimmt stimmt weil sonst muss er sonst macht er den ganzen bild neu wenn
sich hier was ändert
Da muss man sich eh was überlegen.
Ja, ja, das stimmt schon.
Ja, da hast du recht.
so aber selbst die anderen sachen vielleicht wäre es nicht sinnvoller ich
mache das so als ganz was anderes wäre es nicht sinnvoller ich mache das so
und hier oben mache ich nur package chasen und package chasen lockt dass man
das so macht wer das nicht wäre das nicht am sinnigsten dann kopiere ich
nämlich package jason package jason lock danach mache ich einen pms toll danach kopiere ich erst
diesen ganzen anderen krempel machen bild ist was du bei den sechs mann ja ich denke schon
ich brauche aber erstmal muss ich das spielen können das ging ja nicht weil ich kein secure
boot habe gerade genauso machen wir das auch auf der arbeit ja dann kann ich ja nicht so falsch
liegen.
Okay.
Das scheint funktioniert zu haben.
Jetzt installiert er uns .NET.
Das ist, muss man sagen, vielleicht nicht so schön,
weil das nicht so ganz reproduzierbar ist.
Das macht immer was anderes.
Aber,
soll mir recht sein für jetzt.
So, jetzt haben wir .NET installiert.
Und jetzt können wir uns
hier drinne copy
from
Jetzt kopieren wir uns nämlich die
Index HTML.
From build gui
holen wir uns von
build. Slash build.
Kommt nochmal ein Slash build.
Das Bild ist der Ordner, der ich
anlege. Das ist das, was
npm build anlegt. Und da drinnen
gibt es jetzt Index HTML.
Und das kopiere ich
jetzt hier nach build.
Die Benamung ist
vielleicht nicht so hundertprozentig ideal du hast recht ja dort net erst cs
projektdatei oder cs proj wie die wieder die amis immer zu sagen ist so ein
ansatz rein kopieren und bild ja mache ich das hier vielleicht zufälligerweise
schon richtig wie hier mache ich das nicht richtig
index html gut
ja dann zeige ich mal her dann gehen wir jetzt mal hier in die in der cli
in der cli verzeichnis
sagen jetzt hier. .NET
.NET
New Console
Okay, so dann machen wir
Rider auf.
Reader.
Warum nimmst du nicht den offiziellen
.NET Container? Weil der nicht
auf Ubuntu 18.04
aufsetzt.
Sondern auf irgendwas Neuem.
Oder wir gucken mal.
Wir können mal gucken, auf was der aufsetzt.
Aber ich glaube nicht.
Moment.
Hack.
Ne, Repos.
Ich habe in jedem Scheißordner was, was Kekwe heißt.
Der Kekwe Champ CLI.
Trust.
Trust zu allen Projekten.
Wir können mal kurz gucken.
.NET run.
.NET container images.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Dinger heißen.
.NET, Microsoft .NET.
SDK, hä?
Distroless images.
Ich will ja gar kein Container Image bauen.
Wie heißen denn diese die die die.net Container Microsoft.net?
Und dann?
Ja, neun.
What?
Ja.
haben die nicht ihre haben die nicht ihre images auf docker hab doch oder
kann ich nicht irgendwie so locker gibt es nicht irgendwie so eine netz oder sowas
die haben die haben ihre sachen wirklich nicht nur text ne
es ist microsoft.net
die haben wirklich die haben einfach nur sich die die namen hier registriert man
muss den ihre ihre registry nehmen die haben die sache nicht mehr bei docker hab
Ja, du hast recht, Afterlife.
Wo hast du das gefunden?
Ah, da haben sie es drin stehen.
Okay.
Und wo hast du das Preview gefunden?
Aha.
Gucken wir mal, auf was das basiert.
LSB Release.
Ubuntu 24.04 basiert das sogar drauf.
Das ist auf jeden Fall zu neu.
Da machen wir unser eigenes
Image.
Okay.
Dann haben wir jetzt hier unseren
Docker-Container, der läuft. Dann brauchen wir
unsere .NET-Anwendung.
.NET-Anwendung wird ganz simpel werden.
Warum zu neu?
Weil, wenn du
...
Weil wenn du eine
IoT-Anwendung baust,
dann linkt das immer gegen die
G-Lib C-Version von dem
jeweiligen System.
Und dann läuft
deine Anwendung nicht
auf einem älteren System.
so hallo world wo wir nicht wie bei der welt ist übrigens plötzlich gemacht habe wir löschen
es kann noch mal die mkds cli new web
ob new web ist es weil ich will ja den web server haben
Hatte aber nicht 20.04. Neue Probleme mit der 18.04 Version?
Was? Wie? Was meinst du?
Sollte nicht.
GLC sollte immer vorwärtskompatibel...
Also, sag mal, rück...
Nee.
Vorwärtskompatibel heißt das dann in dem Fall eigentlich.
Also, wenn du...
Die neuen enthalten auch immer die alten Sachen.
Sollte zumindest so sein.
So, wie kriege ich denn da jetzt meine Index-HTML drin embedded?
Das heißt, ich teste das jetzt mal hier bei mir ohne Docker-Container.
So, also wir gehen jetzt mal in GUI, Build, Index-HTML.
Das kopieren wir jetzt hier rein.
Und dann müssen wir dem sagen, embedded oder so, gell?
Hier, Build Action, Resource.
Oder, boah, das mache ich so selten.
Ressource?
Copy always?
War das so?
Oh, das ist jetzt... da muss ich jetzt mal überlegen, wie wir das machen.
index html
und jetzt
Prozent kann nicht kann man hier in dieser sagen wie
Ressource oder so
Oh ne, wie war das jetzt nochmal?
Assembly Resources?
Ich habe keinen Blastenschimmer.
Return Embedded Resource.
Ja.
Ja, das...
Embedded Files...
What the hell is Embedded Files Provider?
Ah.
Wie ging das nochmal?
Wie kommt man da...
Ja.
Braucht man da Reflection für?
ja ja aber ich habe ja keine datei die irgendwo liegt die ist ja bei mir in der
excel dann oder in exe beine riedern drin
netz mb resourcen das
Weil Reflection und Zeug
funzt doch nicht.
Soll das ganze Single-File werden?
Ja, so ist das Ziel.
Exzellent.
Der kennt sich aus.
Kratz am Start.
Jaja, das...
Aber das funzt, guck mal.
Das funzt ja mit AOT dann nicht mehr.
Wir können das ja mal ausprobieren.
Machen das jetzt einfach mal weg.
Boah, hier ist ja gar nichts mehr drin.
Der hat ja alle meine Keymaps gelöscht und so.
Okay, warte mal.
Machen wir nochmal hier.
Keymap.
Visual Studio, please.
Okay, wenigstens funzt das.
ja habe ich ja habe ich ja die frage
so also das funzt jetzt.net run hier ach so moment.net run
Es ist nichts Embedded, sagt er.
Oh Mann, also das sind so Dinge, die sind echt immer eklig kompliziert.
Du musst es auf Embedded Resource.
Ist Resource nicht das gleiche wie Embedded Resource?
Weil Embedded Resource geht ja hier gar nicht.
Okay, dann machen wir hier jetzt...
Ach so!
da gibt es unterschiedliche sachen da ist es okay und jetzt aot publish aot
gucken ob das ob das überhaupt mit aot funktioniert weil ich dachte
immer reflection geht mit aot nicht mehr
ok drei stunden später
bild doch funzt okay gut ich habe nichts gesagt
ja gut und jetzt kann man das ausliefern
also also wie geht das get manifest resource name jetzt resource get manifest resource
stream für die ressource mit dem namen hier so und get da kann man doch bestimmt ein file
irgendwie return oder index
davon feiert ja
So, jetzt bilden wir das nochmal.
Ja, ich dachte, dass prinzipiell alles mit Reflection nicht funktioniert.
Okay.
host port 5000 okay das funktioniert schon mal nett okay so einfach ist es nett
Okay, so einfach ist es schon mal nett
Das muss ich bestimmt lesen als Text, oder?
Also einfach
Einfach eine File Return
Geht wahrscheinlich nicht
File Read All
Äh.
Ne, warte mal.
Ich feil.
Äh.
Stream Reader?
Wollen wir jetzt? Oder?
Jo.
Stream.
Stream Reader?
Reader?
Oder?
So.
Ah ja gut.
Das ist jetzt Text.
Da muss ich jetzt noch...
Wie returnt man da jetzt ordentlich was?
Da muss man wahrscheinlich nicht Text,
sondern muss wahrscheinlich sagen
New Stream Content.
Okay.
Aha.
Das geht?
Äh, nicht wirklich, oder?
Ja, Content-Type.
Aber konnte man nicht sagen.
Wenn schon was fertig ist.
String-Content.
Provide HTTP-Content based on a String.
Genau.
das will ich haben
index stream index content gleich new stream reader
index stream to end sagt so jetzt was
was zum teufel text plain
Der sagt doch explizit hier
Da doch irgendwas von
Provides HTTP
konnte, ach ne, nicht HTML
HTTP
Okay, also muss ich wahrscheinlich doch so was
machen wie was jemand im chat kann geschrieben die kontext ok wisst ihr was wir fragen mal chat gpt
da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
in wix content html
content heiter ja so schaue bin ich auch
results content index content aha
minimal api asp.net core return html ok
microsoft macht es aber manchmal schon echt ganz schön kompliziert
Ja.
Gut, dann machen wir das mal hier.
Results, Content.
Okay.
Ich glaube sogar, dass es stimmt, was ChatGP
geschrieben hat.
Da ist die Seite.
Okay, und jetzt
AOT.
Das war ja wieder Krampfe.
By the way,
das hier ist nie Null.
meins budget gpt uns bedanken du bist nice
possible reference nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein
es ist unmöglich dass es mal references
es ist niemals eine reference
weil ich das sage es niemals mal
ok jetzt gucken wir bild localhost port 5000
tag embedded webseite sehr gut so mag ich das nice jetzt muss man schon noch gucken
ob unser docker bild irgendwie funktioniert was man da gebaut haben und dann brauchen wir
ein output output es gibt jetzt eine neue möglichkeit bei docker sachen aus dem container
wieder raus zu kopieren das müssen wir mal gucken klar irgendwie docker output oder sowas
oder minus minus output bild output
genau output kann man nämlich direkt sachen raus kopieren aus dem container image während
dem bild da muss man nicht danach das container image starten und dann was raus kopieren sondern
dann kannst direkt vom bildmann das ist ja neu
jetzt haben wir das ist das also jetzt nur noch kurz überlegen
wir müssen jetzt erst mal copy aus dem docker fall
wir kopieren jetzt wo so überlegen dass das sinn macht was was was hier was hier
baut bauer wir kopieren jetzt alle schon mal das schon mal falsch aus sie
Wir kopieren alle...
Ne, nur die Projektdatei kopieren wir.
Und dann machen wir run.net.net restore.
Richtig.
Dann kopieren wir die cs-Files.
dann kopieren wir die cs files und dann sagen wir dort net ja dann sagen wir hier
im moment dann kopieren wir noch das html das index html und dann machen wir ein bild ob das
jetzt von natürlich nicht warum nicht und zeug fehlt noch
Äh...
Habe ich das irgendwie falsch gemacht?
Was ist daran jetzt denn richtig?
Ach so.
Ich muss das hier oben setzen, gell?
Weil er schon beim Restore abkackt.
Holst du dir Battlefield 6?
Ja.
Ja, holen werde ich es auf jeden Fall.
Was sagt bloß das?
Klappt jetzt.
generating native code
auf der 7 die code war auf der neuen der job aber gar nicht funktioniert
und jetzt minus minus output wie wir das jetzt noch mal
haben wir doch irgendwie ein beispiel gerade
locker minus minus output
output type local des output dir
moment wie was
Moment
Moment, das ist das ganze Image
Ich will ja nur eine Datei rauskopieren
Das stimmt, ByteStrike
Kann ich nicht eine einfache Datei mittlerweile da raus kopieren?
Copy File.
Ich bilde mir ein.
Ich weiß, wie man es machen kann mit Trink 17.
mit ring 17 kann man so machen wie ich hier auch noch beim vm champ gemacht
habe im docker fall am ende
irgendwo habe ich das schon mal gemacht dass man hier sachen raus kopiert aber so war das
war das vielleicht beim fiat champ aber glaube ich auch nicht oder docker file
ach nee ich weiß wie wir es jetzt gemacht haben das licht ist hier nicht im docker
file das ist in dem bild skript haben wir das gemacht in dem bild skript haben wir das gemacht
dann erstellen wir das image und dann kopieren wir aus dem aus dem docker was raus jetzt ist
natürlich blöd dann machen wir jetzt anders wie geht das docker output machen
wir das so dann soll er das soll er das halt da rein schreiben
wird
ob das jetzt von ob das alter
Warum ist das Image so fett?
Ey, ist nicht schlimm.
Ist nicht schlimm, wir brauchen ja nur eine Datei da draus.
Fett.
Pepo, fett.
Image.
naja gut jetzt kopiert den ganzen mist
guck da ist es
was ich nicht ganz verstehe ist was macht es da jetzt eigentlich so lange
macht es überhaupt noch was oder hängt es jetzt
macht nichts das hängt einfach nur wir fragen mal ich bin mal gespannt was chat gpt sagt copy file
rom locker bild to house machine das ist nämlich gar nicht so einfach möglich ja temporäre container
Ja, so mache ich das auch hier.
Genau das machen wir hier.
Ja.
Directly.
Not at build time.
Option 2.
Okay, er sagt Option 2 geht eigentlich gar nicht.
Naja, das ist halt auch im Prinzip das, was ich schon wusste.
Was macht das Ding hier eigentlich?
What the f...
Moment.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Kann das sein, dass sich das irgendwie selbst kopiert?
Hat sich das gerade irgendwie selbst kopiert?
Aber warum?
Im Docker-File ist doch nichts dergleichen.
drin
verstehe nicht
kopiert auch hier nix
das hat sich selbst das hat sich selbst
das kopiert sich selbst irgendwie
Ich gehe mal eins hoch.
Ne, das ist mir...
Du kannst keinen Ordner mounten,
während man im Docker-Build-File...
ok keine ahnung aber ist tatsächlich auch wurscht es funktioniert cd bild
bild da ist es drin cli zack 5000 also das jetzt nur noch kosmetik
sonst wir haben ein dotnet cli programm war 16 mb groß ist ein embedded web server und
html zeug enthält warum das docker bild nicht richtig funzt ein schimmer
das ist nicht so geil aber ist halt so
dass das manns welt jetzt bauen kann als single index html ist halt mega nice
ich habe hier immer noch diesen
ähm
Modell
T-Display S3
Das Teil habe ich hier immer noch liegen.
Ja.
Äh, so Microcontroller
mit Display. Und da wollte ich
wollte ich ja ein Webfront
drauf laufen lassen.
Und wenn man mit
SvelteKit jetzt quasi Single
Pile-Sachen bauen kann,
die trotzdem alles enthalten.
Ist halt nice, weil es immer schwierig
ist, mehr als eine Seite auszuliefern
von so einem Microcontroller.
Weil da muss man eh schon immer tief
in die Trickkiste greifen. Das Ganze
als C-Byte-Array
embedden und dann da ausliefern und sowas.
Aber gut, hat alles funktioniert.
Leute, drei Stunden
für Comeback-Stream reicht es jetzt erstmal.
Ich bin fertig.
Ich bin das nicht mehr gewohnt.
Aber es war schön, dass ihr am Start wart.
Und ich denke mal, ich bin in nächster Zeit wieder ein bisschen öfters da.
Je nachdem, wie es mir geht.
Ich habe euch ja erzählt, was Sache ist.
Jetzt Nudeln mit Lachs.
Ich glaube, jetzt gehe ich noch eine Runde.
Da ist es wieder.
Schon wieder gecrashed.
Keck Wade, Alter.
Ach, weil Werbung kommt. Wieder gecrashed.
Jaja. Egal, ich brauch eh net.
Ähm. Ich geh jetzt wahrscheinlich
nochmal an die frische Luft.
Ah.
Was getrunken.
Leute, wir hören uns. Bis denn.
Macht's gut. See you.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020